this is this is how much you have right
here right to the middle I have very
approached into your space
my first my first term so I was like
dude dude listen are you serious that's
what you're saying oh my Lord of Jesus
oh hell everybody still played at ass
every day well every every uh she every
every minute we were doing something
should be like this
and it couldn't help but see because she
had the size of mine and she it was the
difference of Republicans and she was
reporting in from the committee facility
boy okay I'm like do you sleep at night
or do you just like we pull it in
it's a tweet it's just a tweet thing I
guess
this yeah
okay
um
thank you
so here here's where we're at
um
639 which I know most of you are in the
room for
um is done uh and I have just forwarded
to all the committee members so
um
unfortunately we're printing them up the
copies of it now and it's 29 pages so
that might take a little moment so in
the meantime we do have two other bills
so I thought I'd address if they don't
show up but I guess maybe I'll just
collect
email addresses and send them all to you
okay so but uh we do have two other
bills that we're taking up today so uh
the liquor subcommittee uh the first one
is 279 and we do have an amendment here
for 279. yep
um when it comes to subcommittee I
generally do it myself okay
refers you can do it do you want to do
it
okay here's to pass this amendment
around
okay see see how that that goes around
okay so what this amendment does
um is basically
uh ads that um the for the the under the
current law the fine is five thousand
and up to ten days uh we're going to
change the first offense is going to be
uh find 7 500 rather than 5000 and up to
15 days
but then it goes on and says if there is
documented attendance of the licensed
Personnel at a commission sponsored
educational program before the injury or
death either online or in person if
there is no such documentation
the suspension shall be 30 days
so this is the attempt is to create a
carrot to uh for restaurants and
licensees to uh
make sure all their employees are are
released to the employees they think
might overserve that they would make
sure that they have have a carriage to
be inspired to make sure that their
employees are trained
so
any questions
yes okay
am I uh it doesn't matter just
observation yeah
a change in this latest version the
second offense
the license shall be revoked correct so
that that's a change from the previous
no that's actually current law that's
current law but I mean the the previous
version of this bill that we saw it did
not have that second program because it
was written yeah it was it was setting
up as a separate RSA right so
any other questions any questions from
the audience I have a question
yes um you um
so you've changed the in so that you've
increased the fine and the days right
yes the fine just create increase to
from five to seventy five hundred and
yes but the days went from 10 to 15.
correct but it's still up two
two so that gives the commission a
little bit of wiggle room to decide how
severe
they think the situation is
okay
everybody comfortable with that
I don't have myself I have the correct
we have the correct
the committee here let me actually let
me see
Okay so
uh read it again
I think I should know it by now but
I was born
Sullivan bonniere okay
it's a good self-promotion
and she's okay one two three
so who
is
I'm missing some uh
yeah let me see it
okay
foreign
okay now I got it
okay
okay so representative potusik
the moves ought to pass on the amendment
the amendment number is
oh five two six h
and
second
Oh I thought we were head discussion
okay yeah all right so we have a motion
and discussion okay
I appreciate that you know this this
makes a difference and it ties it to
education however with the first offense
um again I'll use the red park in my
community as an example they could even
with training they could have been fined
and closed 15 consecutive days which
would have really closed them down and
caused people to lose their jobs even in
a scenario where somebody was
intoxicated they went out to their car
and they were empty bear cans all over
it which indicated that there was at
least a good possibility that they
hadn't served them
um that alcohol they drove this person
home but I'm just saying if that had
come to an accident
why you're going to punish them if this
guy was drinking beer in his van or took
a pill or whatever
okay well we do have the commission my
understanding is that they do a long
investigation before the hearing process
and so if it became clear that that
person had been drinking somewhere else
prior to coming into the facility uh
then then that is the reason why it's up
too but would there be a Toxicology test
I mean to know that they had a pill in
their system which is all you know
happens also somebody goes in the
restroom it could snort coke or whatever
right so you think you're saying you
would rather see that stay you'd rather
see that stay at 10 days
no I'm just saying I'm saying I'm just
asking what do you what do you think is
the right answer I'm not the right
answer is I'm not sure even with this
amendment the bill is going to do what
we wanted so you don't want to pass the
bill the amendment at all
you don't want to ever have don't ever
do something or never you want to leave
the current law as it is and only add in
this 30 days
if they don't have training or do you
still that because that's 30 days is one
one business that's putting them out of
business exactly well so 15 days could
also again even if they do the training
anybody else from right yeah I mean I
I have a similar I mean I like the idea
of the training thing like the character
approach
um
I guess this is the existing law or not
this isn't but existing law is 10 days
right so that's that we're not
discussing that the existing law is up
to 10 days and five thousand dollar fine
right uh or 2500 right got that right I
think it's 2500 all but that doesn't
matter
um I think that's what it says here yeah
um
but anyway so yeah my my concern I mean
it's similar it's similar to what
representative borrow says which is
the the goal is to prevent what happened
from happening and it seems to me
changing the initial I mean the law is
on the book as it is with 10 days I
don't know why we need to work with that
if we think training is the ultimate
issue right then maybe that carrot
approach of if you have documentation I
could be comfortable with that but the
idea of changing the other one the
actual penalty yeah so you would rather
see it just leave it at five and ten
five thousand dollars yeah whatever the
original Law is but then add in this
piece then add in this one then that
makes it I mean we can have a separate
discussion of whether or not we think
this is going to accomplish the goal it
is but if this is what we want to do I
don't think we want to change the
initial penalty about that that would be
fine
who who else has a feeling agree with
that concept and to be on the committee
you agree with that representative
Osborne
and representative Vinson who's a member
of the subcommittee what do you think
thank you Mr chairman um
I actually am in favor of the amendment
and the bill the way it is right now is
it stands
um
I think that establishments
um know the deal I personally feel that
the Liquor Commission is not going after
these establishments just to take their
license
if something of the magnitude of someone
to be intoxicated and hurts one of us or
kills one of us or our family members or
someone of the public
of New Hampshire or out of state because
there's a lot of people obviously travel
in and out I just think that the the
punishment uh
fits the crime
um
I just think that it's something that is
just needs to have some
some meat to it so to speak and I don't
mean to be insensitive I don't think
that the like I was going to say I don't
think that the liquor commissioner is
going out and picking on businesses just
to lose their license or find them I
don't think that's what the case here is
and I think they do have good judgment
[Music]
um
to keep us safe I mean what else can I
say I just uh I like the way it is right
now thank you you like the amendment as
is presented I like the way it is right
now presented yes okay uh representative
wolf you have an opinion
thank you Mr chairman
uh yes I agree with my fellow
representative that if
as it is if the onus is such
set high enough then the businesses will
ensure that their bartenders and servers
are trained appropriately
I think if it goes back to the other
you know
well I think there's if you think it's
the training is what's necessary then
raising the other two is maybe
unnecessary
that's that's what I think is what I'm
hearing from these committee members
which is that because we're bringing in
this whole new uh Draconian concept that
we could be shut down for 30 days if you
didn't have training why why do we need
to raise the fine
from five to seventy five hundred or why
do we need to raise the commission's 10
to 15 days well I think this ensures it
it helps to ensure that the training
occurs
and we'll actually would undermine the
trade if they'll get away with that
right well I hear you all right okay all
right yeah representative Sullivan yeah
I mean I think
I think um what representative hunt was
saying is is what how I view it so if I
own a bar and I have this current
regulatory framework in front of us and
we now have this new regulation coming
in saying that we need to
we have this current law that we
understand or if if we get caught
breaking this law or violating this
regulation then we could lose our
licensing up to or our business close
for 30 days and we pay this increased
fine if if the people haven't been
trained there's now an incentive to
train train people if we think training
is going to be the solution to this
problem which it sounds to me from
talking to people over the last few
weeks people are concerned that maybe
these bartenders aren't properly trained
um I don't know that the 15 day
suspension or the changing of the
initial framework in any way
incentivizes it doesn't even impact the
incentive to train people
um because once you start training it
you are exempt from this 30-day thing so
I think the 30-day thing is the carrot
that's going to try to
try to get them going that's how I
interpret the way this law works
and so that's that's why I said we
shouldn't play with the other one and I
got it John and incentivize people to go
for for uh 30-day training if that's
what you really want
so you you want to respond you
you don't have to yeah I did
okay representative uh thank you Mr
chairman
um some of you
can you hear me uh I uh put forward this
uh uh Amendment and think it should pass
I am a licensed server in the state of
New Hampshire I went through the
training I used to test I've been a
bartender on and off since the 60s and I
believe this is the deterrent I think
another carrot which could be hung out
there in the future is that if all your
servers are licensed the insurance
premiums might go down
which would which would mean that their
liability would be decreased so I think
this is a good Amendment and I think it
should pass and if for some reason we
want to improve it next year we can
improve it next year but to put
something in place like this now is very
important thank you
okay
okay uh let me make sure I hit everybody
who's on the uh subcommittee first and
okay like Burrows you're you're like you
would like that new proposal right
this amendment no no the new proposal
not the amendment but to to take this
amendment and and put the 75 down back
to 5 000 yeah and to 15 back to 10. okay
all right so that's and Representative
Vincent doesn't like that okay so now
I'll throw it open to the other
committee members representative
I just wanted to highlight
that this amendment allows for one
strike and then you're out there's no
um there's no
um leeway for the commission
to
examine circumstances on a second
offense and I I don't know that that's
current law I'm trying to find it but
maybe we could clarify
so that would be something else that's
different from the previous version that
we saw that is concerning if that's the
case yeah I think
I think we need the commission to have
some we can't think of everything in our
rules so we need to give them some
flexibility and if the rule says that
one strike you're out that's concerning
to me
other members that you may represent a
Mac later
um I don't think it says one strike in
your route I think it says if you
obviously if you have a second uh
situation it's much more serious and I
would expect the Liquor Commission would
take that into account and and and do
their proper investigation it does say
second offense and you lose your license
yeah
shall be revoked but it has to be it has
to be proven though
that so it's not just that oh wait a
minute okay I ran over somebody because
he was drunk
um but we're not going to investigate it
they might find out that he again had
had all his beers in his car or
something like that so I don't think
it's one strike and you're out I think
it's two strikes and you're out
that's the way I read it well as as a
final verdict right okay that's a
semantic but okay I can strike you're
out yes other than that I support uh uh
representative Vinson representative
Walsh and representative petusic that I
think that as this bill is written
although I would be willing to
compromise I I think it it's it it
really puts some teeth into the bill and
that's what we need some real teeth
thank you I think I think we I mean
we we trust the Liquor Commission to do
to do investigations and I think the
electorate commission maybe if we had
language on the second Offense for the
Liquor Commission to decide whether or
not
the circumstances weren't a permanent
local closing down of the establishment
I think if that's automatic based on the
statute uh I think that seems a little
severe and it takes away from the people
on the ground doing the investigation
yeah
no not yet okay because we might be
mending it some more okay
yes
go ahead
oh me thank you waiting to hear my name
sorry thank you Mr chairman that's right
so I I just want to be clear so that we
know what we're doing when we do what we
do if we do this
and I'm not arguing against this but
with respect to the language on line 15
for the second offense which we Now
understand will be a determination made
by The Liquor Commission the enforcement
Folks At The Liquor Commission the
on-premises license shall be revoked
this potentially could occur
within a year
or it could be five or ten years later
a second offense is a second offense and
second strike you're out and it could be
10 15 years later just so we understand
I'm fine with that because a second
offense is a second offense it's the
first offense is so serious
that the establishment needs to make
sure that it never happens again not
just within a year or three years or
five years but never again thank you
okay representative Getz
I'm just offering this as a possibility
in terms of giving the Liquor Commission
um some leeway depending on what they
find in their investigation that we
consider changing for the second event
for the second offense the on-premises
license shall be revoked to the
on-preferences license may be revoked
oh go separate the on and off premises
no
sorry uh excuse me
um maybe I wasn't clear yeah changing
shell to May
to give the Liquor Commission some
leeway in their determination but this
is current law now
I understand that
um but the disc okay I have not read the
current law there seem to be some
discussion
um uh representative Ammon I think was
was questioning whether it's current law
but there was some discussion as to
whether
shall is too rigid
um so I'm offering as an alternative May
okay
representative texting
well I was actually going to make the
same suggestion that Representatives
representative Gibbs made my concern
with any of these things is to deny what
I would call judicial discretion in this
case it's the the commission has that
position
there are things that are going to be
on the line I don't want to I don't want
to punish somebody unfairly and I I have
an issue if it's if if if the second
offense is six months later I agree
you've really got an issue but if it's
15 years later
and it's right on the line with this law
they're out of business period the end
and sometimes things are unavoidable so
for that reason I would like to leave
more latitude on the commission's part
rather than less
it's not a lot more but it's a little
bit less so
that's my input right
representative Harvard
this would if you have a a brawl in your
bar for some reason
of you know the Democrats fighting uh
Ammon you know
[Laughter]
guess who won that fight
but and you know what I mean I mean
everybody saw I was thinking a car
accident took beer in the car but if you
have if you have a dispute and they
could all be sober
but uh and had three drinks each in the
last four hours and somebody gets hurt
is that uh is that going to be
applicable to this this uh punishment it
says bodily injury so it could be
anything so that's where the up two
comes up to come kicks in so the answer
is yes
so I would I would say that in terms of
the second offense as representative
that's what we pointed out first you
have to they have to have documented and
proven that the second effects offense
actually did occur right that that was
you know that that
the licensee it travels with the
licensee
licensee so
yeah it's with the licensee
Valley and it would not follow that
manager it would be the Applebee's
yes the Applebee's license and is that
that location license or that would be
if Applebee's has multiple license it
would it'd have to be that location
that that specific lace to that location
um well my personal opinion is I'm I I
take these things the legislation
um
incrementally
um we have over the years have not done
anything you know we've had this bill
put in multiple times to mandate the
training
and
um and we've always the committee has
failed to ever do that so given that I'm
the one who said well why don't we do it
this way
um I I guess I'm I'm more apt to say
that I was offering that up
um as a compromise from
not passing something
the changing of the of the penalties and
the time frames
um I think was uh trying to relate it to
the the current
that we would take more steps further
what the bill was but since I've come in
with this kind of compromise I guess I'd
be more apt to be willing to stay with
the
um 5000
and and 10 days on the assumption that
then this is only a little incremental
piece it's a carrot so it's a comp and
the compromise is a carrot and it seems
a solution to the problem without having
to dramatically change it so if you know
if the Senators feel differently they
want to have more or as as
representative said if we need to come
back and visit it because we feel that
that wasn't enough you know we can
certainly do that but I I guess I'd be
more inclined to
um stick stick with the current law but
just add in this New Concept so how many
people were outrageous to clarify the
New Concept is the if they're if they
have not had the training it's the
automatic 30 days what do we think about
the land in the second shall revoke
license on the second offense I would
just gets current law child be revoked
for second offense that's current law
oh current law is three
oh geez three what okay so that would
turn the shell into May okay I guess so
what so right now the current what is it
does it say anything about the second
offense in the colonel law
okay
so so I I would be more apt to leave the
current law in place I'm comfortable
with that and just only thing to change
is just adding in this extra extra 30
day uh the 30-day only ifs if on the
first offense 30 days added uh if the
train if the employee didn't have
training yes so Mr chairman because I I
think illustrations always help if we
could go back to the unfortunate
event that was described To Us by the
family that lost their daughter what
would happen here to this establishment
it being the establishment's first
offense right that they could be fined
five thousand dollars correct and be
closed for up to 15 days 30 days 30 days
well it says it would be mandatory
Thursday now it would be 30 days because
yeah I hadn't gone through that yeah oh
I see because because from the testimony
I heard
it appears that there had been no
training correct of the the servers
right bartender so for the loss of that
particular life we're talking about 30
days and five thousand dollars
on the first
the establishment's first offense
if there are any subsequent offenses of
this nature
by this establishment whether it be a
year five years or ten years then right
now unless the language has changed the
language says shall be revoked rather
than may be revoked that's in this bill
but under current law so what I'm I'm go
I'm now inclined to just uh take the
current law and just add in that on the
first offense
the 30-day
kicks in if they don't have training
under current law it is now if I
understand it it's up to 30 to 60 days
for the second violation
that's okay so maybe we want to put it
in RSA put it in the statute okay yeah
and then and then the third offense
is is they lose their license the
license is gone so now we have to change
this to this the third because right now
we would draft another one we would be
drafting another amendment yes well but
I want to get consensus that that's the
way we want to go before I would just
say because this is this is multifaceted
with throwing all kinds of numbers
around it it's going to be really
helpful to actually see the next
iteration of the amendment I hear you so
okay all right representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman
um just for clarification I'd just like
to go through this to make sure I'm I'm
understanding it correctly and I'll be
as quick as I can because I understand
that we'll see a new written version so
for the first offense if there's
training the licensee would be fined
five thousand dollars and the license
suspended for up to 10 days correct if
there's no documentation of training
this is license shall be suspended for
30 days correct for the second defense
the license shall be suspended for 30 to
60 days up two yes up to 30. right is it
up two and that's in rule no it's not it
doesn't say up to it just says 30
30 to 60 days is there's no up to when
the second offense so that's what we
would put in this test that's where we
were 30 60 days and for the third
offense the license shall be revoked
correct and how much money on the 30 to
60 on the second offense yeah how much
is the fine in the 30 60.
no second offense
it's still at five still five so there's
no step up in the fight it's 2500 the
person oh the first is 2500 yeah then it
goes to five
okay
I know the current owner okay uh yes and
that's a rule
um how do we Define serious bodily
injury so how do you guys Define serious
bodily injury
okay
um representative Sullivan yeah so I'm I
just started thinking so we're gonna try
to get people to get trained that's our
goal so this training offered by the the
alcohol commission right
um Okay so
my question is how much does it cost
anything is it free a free online thing
great okay and then so if I if I have a
bar and I have a server who gets trained
and then that server leaves to go to
you know representative hunts Barr did
that travel with them or do they have to
get retrained I feel like that's
really it does and does it expire at
some period of time
okay
so so if I got trained once 10 years
later I'm still covered by that
okay so just so everybody understands
what happens that the training obviously
the the file that's kept on that
employee's training is klept by the
employer
right does the commission keep fi you
will you would have records so if that
employee showed up at a different
facility you would still have records
that that employee did have the training
okay
okay right so you get somebody to
suitable framing all right okay
representative I just have a question
about the training I've never seen the
training so obviously I mean I haven't
taken the training so
um and I've I heard somebody disparage
the training as quote a joke now I
understand that anybody can characterize
anything any the way anybody wants to
characterize the training so I'm not
saying that the training is a joke I'm
just saying I heard this but that
prompts the question is this training
these training modules have have you
developed these in-house
um or with the assistance of um uh
others in the field
and for example Partners in other states
could you just describe briefly how you
put the training modules together or how
you obtain them thank you
yes so they are created in-house
um the training goes over a very
comprehensive amount of information it
includes license requirements and
includes fake ID detection and includes
detection on visible signs of
intoxication it also goes over server
liability license liability and also
discusses responsible business practices
for license establishments that they can
Implement
in order to prevent instances like this
it goes over statutes that are relevant
to not only their license type but the
entire industry we have this training
program is updated every year we
evaluate it every year we are part of
several National groups in terms of the
regulation of alcohol we are on
education committees within those groups
where we meet annually and share
training programs with each other so
there's a lot that goes into these these
training programs we have ones that are
specified for one day licenses we have
ones that are specific to retail tobacco
the there's management directed
licensing there's server directed
licensing there's off sale directed
licensing there's on sale directed
licensing there's direct shipper
training so all of that you know there's
several different training programs we
have a training program that's specific
for Liquor security
so we've we've tried to cover all the
basis within each licensed establishment
and much of the training is data driven
and relevant to liability New Hampshire
laws and regulations for the question
so in thank you for the comprehensive uh
response
so in short
would you say that um your uh training
piece
um would uh would would pass scrutiny as
best practices because of how
comprehensive it is the work that you do
the consultations with peers and so
forth that you would feel comfortable
having it uh looked at in terms of best
practices and and you you feel very
confident that it would it would pass
with flying colors absolutely thank you
okay representative
uh thank you I think last time you were
here I asked you this question and I'm
not clear on whether you would do
in-house training in other words if I
had a bartender not a bartender owner
want to put on a class in person now how
much would that cost zero zero zero okay
um
secondly we mentioned that a licensee in
a case that could lose their license how
about the server How about if there was
a specific server involved would they
lose their certificate of training
there there is no there is no bartender
or server license in this state there is
a potential for criminal charges against
a specific server the training is just a
training certificate identifying that
you took the training there's no server
license there's no this is John Hunt's
rule of licensure we create license so
we can take it away so if we don't if
you don't have a license there's nothing
for us to take I'm asking about the
certificate could you revoke the
certificate
no okay thank you
yes representative Walsh
uh just going back to the new verbiage
for
the new amendment that we're working
potential Amendment yes potential
Amendment so for the second offense
is there a dollar amount I think that
needs to be stepped that was that was my
all my notes here can we go through the
three steps so the first step is you say
was 2500
and up to or just says 10 days it is a
10 day it's a drop dead 10 days
okay
2510 days
the second offense
the second offense is
a suspension for 30 to 60 consecutive
days
and an administrative fine of five
thousand
and that's not up to that's a fine of
five thousand correct well it's a shall
not exceed five thousand okay so that
isn't up too that's an up two okay
whereas the 2500 it's hard on the first
offense
that is it shall not exceed either
that's enough two also correct okay so
that's up to up to up to 2500 hard 10
days
statute or rule this well this
combination is evidently combination of
two so so statue only a statute allows
for a maximum fine of five thousand and
for uh penalties that include suspension
and or up to revocation that so to set
the limits correct it didn't set the
tier system the tears are in rule so the
second offense
um is actually kind of has its own tiers
as it is right now okay so for the
second offense a license suspension for
30 to 60 consecutive days or an
administrative fine which shall not
exceed five thousand and a suspension of
not less than 10 nor more than 60
consecutive days oh so it's not even one
it's Ten Ten to Ten to sixty it's if you
you
so it would be
it's tough to describe it would be if
you do a five thousand dollar fine then
there is not less than 10 nor more than
60. but you can have a suspension for 30
to 60. if you don't do a fine
oh so you the commission has a wiggle
room on the fine
license suspension for 30 to 60
consecutive days or an administrative
fine which shall not exceed 5000 and a
suspension not less than 10 or more than
60.
excuse me so kind of contract have you
gotten into these situations I'm trying
to imagine what the process is that
you're going through with all of these
different combinations and
permutations of rules we're currently
rewriting this section of role a good
time for us to be revisiting it isn't it
this sounds good we're actually right in
the middle so we're absolutely Byzantine
yes
well it it does feel like it is a lot of
wiggle room in there which obviously the
legislature would never intentionally do
that but so but they did it when they
just sent the caps and then you guys
within the penalty section of the
statute we are required to consider
aggravating and mitigating factors when
applying penalties
aggravating and mitigating factors are
actually outlined in rule as to what
those can what those are training is
actually an aggravating or a mitigating
Factor so that is something when we have
a rule that says the penalty range is
such training is actually accounted
correct if you have it it's a mitigating
if you don't it's an aggravating
so that's what I believe this range is
is we are required by Statute to take
into account those aggravating and
mitigating factors when applying the
range of penalties okay representative
Gibbs
thank you
um could you provide the committee uh
with your current rules
um on penalties both
um the steps and the description of the
aggravating here's the problem with that
this bill has to be out
tomorrow
ah okay and unless you want to come back
we've got to figure this out today
or we have to retain the bill
so I think we can come up with something
and then number three three step three
values like it's just a total outright
repo three is for a third offense
license revocation okay so we got three
set okay we got three set so the issue
now really is the one to two correct
okay and if
um
the
uh so that I I guess what we if I if so
not all the more reasons maybe to go
back to that five thousand you because
that for the first offense because
that's an increase from twenty five
hundred
yes right so the first offense being
being
um
is being okay so if we go if we go to
five thousand
and then and it's it's it is the up to
10 days did you say not to exceed
to 10 days okay
so that that's the 10 days of oh no I'm
sorry the fine the fine shall not exceed
2500 the suspension is for 10 days the
first event is 410. so all the reason
why 10 days is a good number too
so then the issue is the second
violation yes Mr chairman how can for
the second violation the on-premises
license be revoked and on the third it'd
be revoked so you get to a third you can
take it out I'm thinking we're gonna
going to take out the second we're just
going to have the first events yes
um and do we do we want to really wait
to the Third
that's it to provoke good question
do we
yes has anybody ever been twice yeah
have you ever had a scenario where
the operation was so egregious that you
wanted to revoke the license on the
first offense but were unable to
yeah yes but were you able to do it on
your current law that would be this case
the case we have in front of us now only
Rachel said we would have what well so
is there a way to structure the sentence
in such a way that revocation is always
an option but after the third offense
there is no choice
that's what right now
well yeah I know right now I am in terms
of right right now the penalty is 10
days and a fine not exceeding 2500. that
is the only option no matter how bad no
matter how bad it is no matter
aggravating or mitigating factors but if
we can pass something today yes with
this amendment it would be at least 30
days
if the person didn't have the training
well no I I understand that but
I wanna on the one hand I want to give
them more latitude saying I can pull
your license on the first offense if you
are really egregiously bad but on the
other hand I'd like to extend it and
leave it where we have three strikes and
you're out
okay but I also don't want to screw the
whole process up so that nothing gets
done so so if I understand correctly Mr
chairman what you're saying
representative Saxon is you're you'd
want to you would want to give the
discretion to The Liquor Commission that
to be a little more severe that they
they could be so they could be very
severe with the first correct judgment
and revoke correct and or they could be
on the second but by the time you get to
the third we have nothing to do we are
saying by what we the action that we're
taking that the commission would be
mandated to revoke no extern extenuating
circumstances boom done on the third so
if one maybe two maybe three no maybe
right okay
um yeah but just to to clarify that on
the third offense
um just because something happened again
it wouldn't be revoked they these Liquor
Commission would still have to to
investigate and and yeah that all still
exists okay have we ever had a second
offense
we've never had a second offense
so I guess I I I'm I'm I'm more apt to
um
if we
I mean if we've never had the second
events then we would probably want to go
ahead with the revoking of it at a
second time events right
representative Gibbs you uh no I I
wouldn't I would not agree with that I
think there should I think the three
things the tier
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future and I think it makes sense to
since we know that Liquor Commission
will investigate thoroughly they've made
that clear
to leave them
a number of different options that's
what I would write okay so if we if we
liked if we're pro-choice here we like
lots of three steps lots of options
options would be
um that we think uh if the first
violation
should be up to up to five thousand and
up to 10 days
the second violation is up to ten
thousand
and uh it's one to two months or 30 to
60 days
now third
third violation is the revoke
but
the governor on is and regardless if
it's the first second or obviously the
third is a revolution either one in the
first or second if it is that a an
employee does not have the training
there's an automatic 30-day suspension
how does everybody think about that no
no no no no no go on after the third
three strikes no no nothing excuse me
doesn't matter was one two or three
regardless of one two or three if the
employee did not have training
it's an automatic 30 days
so you're you're okay that this the
example we had today you know the for
this hearing that that that the worst
thing that could happen to that that
business
which I probably actually did happen was
that and we're guessing no they probably
they got fined up to 2500 because it was
the first violation
they got fined up to 2500 and they got
suspended for 10 days but they hid the
sign in the back room you're okay with
that I'm saying that that is okay
because remember it's up to these
amounts and it's the person wasn't
licensed
um then obviously the fine should be
higher but I don't think that that in
itself is a cause for revocation of a
license it has to be a totally
out of a world type of offense
did I see your hand go up tell you
unfortunately you need to come to a mic
so I'm sure all the world wants to hear
what you have to say
uh good morning Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Mike Summers I'm the president CEO of
the New Hampshire lodging and Restaurant
Association obviously we're quite keenly
interested in this bill so my concern
with tier one no training automatic 30
days automatic 30 days it's basically
you're just suspending the license the
business is not going to survive
so uh at that point it's one strikey
route so I would I would request
respectfully request that you consider
making it up to 30 days so that the
commission has the ability to if it's a
more egregious occurrence then you you
bring the heat if it is something that
uh you know a terrible accident happened
whatever a fight bite breaks out in a
bar then in that incident instance uh
the commission has discretion uh based
on a variety of factors but again with
the mitigating and aggravating factors I
think you're almost forced to have the
up to standard because I think that
that's going to be required for them to
really do their work
and then the second violation is
automatic 30 to 60 days
yeah I mean that's the current standard
so it kind of is and then uh 5 000 for
the first one ten thousand for the
second I I think we can live with that
yes again I think that's the current law
you probably could live with it well no
because I think the first offense is
2500 you know right updating those
amounts I think that is reasonable and
appropriate and again uh the nature of
the story that was shared is just uh
horrific but
um I guess the other thing that I would
share with you just as you as you
contemplate this piece of legislate you
know please recall in the state of New
Hampshire we have a lot of family-owned
businesses that have been here for 75
years or more so when you talk about one
two three strikes I mean that could
literally the way this is drafted in my
understanding is this could really be
spread out over 75 years but you could
still have your license suspended so I
don't know how you address that but I
just I I give you that put that out that
that is a caveat right okay thank you
thank you very much does anybody has
specific questions to him no okay okay
thank you yes
excuse me Mike we do have a question
not for him okay thank you okay so I
want to before I take questions I want
to have Mark come back and Danielle
so what we're look playing now with is
the the first
is to be up to five thousand so we're
doubling that fine
and up to 30 days so that gives the
commission a fair amount of negotiating
I guess we could say we say uh yeah well
in terms of whether it should say 25 to
5 but or whether we just say up to 10
about to five for that first violation
would you rather have the 25 floor still
still there
yeah a range a range is preferable
because it gives us so for first
violation 25
to 5.
and up to 30 days
okay Mr chairman before we start going
on to the second and the third if we
could just get clarity on the first okay
what Clarity would you like Clarity here
is I think I just heard
that that if in an offense
in the Judgment of the commission under
the first
up to five 25 to 5
000 2500 to 5 000 in up to 30 days that
that up to that if the commission and
let's just use the the immediate case
that's in view with in all of our minds
did you you might go for the 30 days you
can't revoke but you can go to 30 days
what I think I just heard was 30 days is
going to shut the establishment down
which is tantamount to revocation now
that that's a judgment and it doesn't
necessarily mean that's going to happen
but that's that and I don't mean to
suggest it to test it's snowing we just
heard is inaccurate but uh up to 30 days
if it's tantamount to revocation why
don't we just say or revocation
obviously if you're
if you own 10 locations
Closing one down for 30 days is it it's
not not that's not the end it's not at
the end so that again now you're just
taking consideration the size of the
nature of the business so because
earlier on we were talking about making
revocation optional on the first offense
in the second offense right while making
it mandatory on the third but that seems
so I I guess yeah so let's that how
about if we go to the 25 to 5 and then
say up to 15 days except if there's an
employee if the employee didn't have the
training
the 30 day
Draconian gets kicked in
and just go and then instead of going
the 30 days ago 15 days you know go back
to this or 10 days which is the current
law right the 10 days is the current law
so if we go back to current the current
law 10 10 days so no revocation so no no
the revocation the Draconian revocation
occurs uh level at if you had three
offenses
okay Mr chairman can I add yeah just for
clarification uh because I know
everybody analytically is trying to put
this together in their heads just to
representative Terry's uh point this
doesn't preclude due process there will
be due process there's a hearing that
triggers
in 10 days
after this is implemented number one
number two is we only have control of
liquor
alcohol in these establishments that
does not close them down for selling
food
so they still stay open which has been
which has been a point of contention
that's an interesting point they still
stay open it's just they can't they
can't sell their vehicle
thank you
okay representative post do you have a
comment
um no that was sort of what I was
looking for
um and I I think that's uh uh rep sphere
just uh proposed the 30 days I think
that would be with them being able to
serve and not being closed down
um I think to 30 days is a better option
okay
yes representative Burroughs
I just want to clarify so if we do 30
days do you have discretion not to take
it up to 30 days on the first one wait
if we do this correct if it's up to then
in theory the suspension would be 0 to
30 days okay got it
yes representative Gibbs
thank you um
okay are we talking up to 30 days
if there is training or up to 30 days if
there is no training what we were
looking at uh it had nothing to do with
training at this point with the training
is it's it's sort of like but don't we
hang them out there I I still think that
that's where that's what the intent of
the legislation was but I I did not
realize that a that they had this tier
system and B is that it's time for that
whole rulemaking process to be Revisited
so
um what I'm suggesting is that I think
we still do want to make a
differentiation
between when there has been training and
when there has not been trained right
right but we if in that case we would
say taking in what is the current rules
the current what is the current
situation and where do we we're stepping
in and saying uh this fight you know
putting in this this penalty if I could
say something so training is in the
aggravating and mitigating factors it's
already it's already an aggravating or
mitigating those are required to be
considered when looking at penalties so
when you have a range it allows for the
aggravating and mitigating factors if
you have a significant amount of
mitigating factors you can receive
penalties on the lower end of the range
if you have a significant amount of
aggravating factors right you can
receive higher here's the reason why I
have a problem with that and that is
that most of the times these are
first-time offenses
yes okay that even if it's mitigating
the penalty is not severe enough
that's that's the penalty right that's
where I'm stepping in and saying
legislatively
that we want we want to do correct we
want to do something so even if we were
just to leave the way things are now
okay and that we still think that if the
person did not have training whether
it's first second you know violation
well the second doesn't matter because
second you're going to get suspended for
30 days anyways so really what we're
only talking about is the first
violation
if the employee did not have training
what you know is 30 days appropriate now
given that the restaurant can still stay
open
they just can't serve
so effectively then I I don't mean to be
argumentative here or to we're trying to
get to conclusion together but but
effectively then what we're saying is
that in the case that's immediately in
view
that that the value of that human life
that has been lost because of the shall
I say the negligence of the
establishment's owner to not require
training or to make sure that the
employee did not follow the appropriate
training was a 30-day suspension to be
able to serve liquor that's the and
because the Public's going to look at
this in in such a way and they're going
to say well they basically just said
that her life was worth 30 days
it's a way of looking at it so there's
well okay so let me cut to the cut to
the chase so the question then is should
we say instead of for the first
violation it's 10 days so we just simply
say up to 30 days given that that is a
considered mitigating Factor
or do we want to articulate in the
statute that the 30 days is because of
the lack of training
that's what I think in other words if we
just leave the world alone leave this
Byzantine structure that they have alone
all we want to say articulate is it
doesn't matter first second or third you
know that because was sick really second
or third it just means it really is
going after that first violation that if
somebody dies then yeah you got you guys
can't serve liquor for 30 days because
your employees weren't trained
yeah yeah
yes and then and then and then in
response to the public saying you just
all you did is revoke the license for 30
days we say there could be a whole host
of circumstances here that we could not
see in advance but look at what we do on
the second offense because we give the
Opera the the the possibility of
revitation we have never had a second
offense
in all these years we've never had one
so we never that problem never occurred
I understand the reason why this bill is
in front of us is what happens if that
first offense is so catastrophic and
we're saying 30 days and we're saying if
the employee didn't have the training
and that's the value we're putting on
the life that was just lost that's
correct representative Jackson
so
I think that's appropriate I want to
recognize a comment that was made
earlier and we've kind of skipped over
we have the issue in New Hampshire of
many of our restaurants are
intergenerational
there are several that I can think of
that have been the same family for most
of the last century
and so as a consequence would it be
reasonable to add after when you get to
the second or third offense to say
within a like within a 15-year period
otherwise you have the potential of
having
something occur five years ago and
you're going to put somebody else out of
business 15 years from now so much with
like a driver's license where you can
accumulate and your points run off
give it time that's my first 15 years
would be good so I see your spirit but
let me get this address so have you ever
cons we ever considered a timeline are
we thinking that where that's being
written in role right now right now
there's
again the rules are are all over the
place some require a look back of the
entire violation history some are look
back of three years some have specific
standards of 24 months so we are trying
to clean that up in rule to say that how
long the look back is for the history
okay so now I'm going to do something
that no one probably expected
because you're working on these rules
and because the liquid commission often
takes the consideration of what this
committee requests
is it possible that we just retain this
bill and you'll have these rules done by
next September
that we can revisit those rules and that
you will put in this 30-day suspension
for the first
offense and also put in something to
make sure that no business nobody that
there isn't some kind of expiration so
it doesn't last forever is that possible
okay represent a spear
uh two two points and one of them I
think nobody's going to like
but one of the uh the idea of putting a
limit between the time frames between
the first and second
I'm not so sure I think I like that
because we don't know how many didn't
get caught
and I know that's been set on driver's
licenses as well
they don't catch everybody
but the that's another issue okay but
you let you put the penalty down at 2500
to 5K that's the current uh right that
was what I was going to propose for the
first offense right that I do have a
problem with that's saying that we're
not increasing the penalty in any real
way well it's right now it's first
offense is 2500. yeah I would like to
bring it back up to 5000 which is what
you said a little while ago right okay
but which I don't think the restaurant
they were opposed to yeah they weren't
opposed to it okay Mr chairman this is
where I believe your institutional
history your longevity as chair of this
committee will come into play because
with respect to the question I'm about
to ask as well as the folks here from
The Liquor Commission and that is so
we're beginning to hear questions about
look backs
all right we're talking about it up here
in terms of time frames and whatever and
now we're hearing that there are look
backs in the rules they're considering
respect you're considering it or it is
there are certain parameters for certain
penalties it's existing correct there
are look back periods existing all right
so Mr chairman because you have the
history here this fascinates me from the
standpoint of Statute and Rule making
right was it the ever the intent in
statute that rules be developed that
would take into account look back
periods rather than have it be in
statute uh I would say this is the first
time we have ever I've ever dealt this
deeply into these penalties so this
might so every other time we've ever had
these bills this issue uh look backs it
never came up because I never like
frankly I didn't know what the fines the
first second or third tier all the
legislation that
um I guess I'm not supposed to mention
names too often but the certain
representative that people know who's
put this bill in multiple times it was
always about mandating training up front
it was for all employees to be no I
don't mean this to be at all a critical
or judgmental because I'm in a
fact-finding mode right now so what you
folks do with respect to look backs is
not because you necessarily understood
that this was the intent of the law or
the specific language of the law because
there is no specific language in the law
but would you consider prudent and
reasonable and so you just did that on a
discretionary basis correct so stat
their statute requires us to create
rules based on
um a enforcement policy and rules around
penalties
and it's only set the max penalties as
the five thousand dollar fine and then
it says that rules around suspension
revocation things like that so that's
what the in all the rules are based off
of the statutory requirement for us to
create rules regarding the enforcement
policy of how we will handle penalties
thank you okay yep okay representative
Wilson do you have a question
yes I would hope that after retaining
that the verbiage would be much like
what representative spear said it's much
firmer not this up to I would like to
see the first offense be a solid 5000 or
you know something that is very
definitive I'd say start at five
thousand and same with the days
that it's a firm 30 days not up to
do you agree with that or do you do you
prefer a wiggle room I think the
commission has always remained neutral
on on these issues and left it up to the
committee to to actually put forth the
rules that we follow on a daily basis I
will say that in your history and your
you know logic says that deterrence
deterrents are there as was mentioned
earlier with time being solidified and
fines being solidified
That's History
he's the president thank you candidate
he has to be careful
well Mr chairman the other thing that Mr
chairman with respect to Mr
with respect to representative Walsh's
suggestion here or request this also
plays in the in the favor of the
commission because there's no as he as
you and others are describing this
wiggle room
uh 10 up to you know 10 on to 30 or 2500
to 5 000 or whatever so if anybody's
really upset about whatever fine or
sanctions or levied shall we say
whatever sanctions are levied if there's
no wiggle room the commission can say
well you go blame the legislature
because that's what they passed rather
than
um blame us because we were too harsh
within a certain range of 10 to 30 days
so we're the ones who take the Heat and
not the commission
and that's why we get the big bucks so
if we were to retain this Bill yes uh we
would have the expectation that the
department would have their new rule
which they would be working with the
interested parties in generating that
rule okay so they would have a new rule
ready
um I guess I would dare say don't have
to send it to rules committee before you
you bring it to us first and but it
would we would meet uh and we can we
have we can meet in the summer or week
in September we have a summer deadline
right now that we internal deadline for
the 600 girls which are the entire
penalty structure you have a summer you
have a summer sun you've got it we're
hoping to have a first draft on by
Summer Okay so theoretically when the
first draft is done
um this this committee I I do have the
authority even though we don't aren't
allowed to meet in July and August but I
could have the authority to call the
subcommittee and to review those uh
amendment that Amendment and see where
we're at and um and but if nothing else
if things are not getting resolved and
people don't you know feel one way or
the other come by October we would have
to have the bill out of committee so we
would have something by then but by
retaining it at least then we get that
negotiating process and I think that
you've gotten huge amount of guidance
today and so therefore you know what you
know where sort of where we're we're
looking at so retirement with respect to
your proposal and the disclosure of
Summer I'm wondering if you can be any
more definitive about that because
Summer goes for three months from the
middle of June to the middle of
September so are you able to provide any
any more certainty within that time
range you could go up right as soon as
they have it done they'll mail it to us
right so we're not we don't want to wait
until their deadline you have a goal we
want to weigh in before the deadline
it's true so so in other words once
they've got some rough draft of what
they do what's your hope our hope is I
would say July AI at this point okay we
have we have drafts but these are
connected with the 200 rules so we had
to write the 200 rules okay so not
September 20th okay thank you
in representative just to add a little
bit more to that these uh this point
system that has shown in its uh infant
stages to be very fair to industry has
been presented nationally and gotten
higher claims so we I think everybody at
least here knows and and I know industry
knows that
um we we are thinking about them when
when we look at accountability and we
think about some of the things that were
brought up by Mr Summers that is is very
valid uh as far as just
that Mom and Pop own uh establishment
for years
um we understand that and and we want to
see them in compliance
be be very successful
okay so uh for discussion representative
patusek has withdrawn as a motion and
his new motion is for retaining and
that'll be second by me representative
purcelli yes thank you
um and I appreciate that we're going to
retain it so we could look at the rules
that's great but the original problem
that I think we're trying to address is
the concept of training so I would like
to over the course of your evaluation of
the rules separately I'd like to see
maybe working with the industry if there
are any improvements or issues with the
training that have been reported
anecdotally so I think the a rigorous
training program as you've described is
great but if the server is not making
good judgment that really is the problem
that we're trying to solve so how do we
make sure that servers are doing the
right thing and they feel comfortable
with the decisions that they're making
at the you know busy time of operating
their business so I'd like to see some
type of report or evaluation working
with the industry since we did have
these anecdotal messages that the
training was not comprehensive or
adequate and I'd like to understand that
a little bit we have better training
maybe God forbid one life is too many
but maybe better training will yield
better results thank you representative
and and to that
um I will state that
um our training right now
um we we have a evaluation program that
we do after each one of them when
representative Terry brought that up
earlier
um there's no other term that that burns
through us because we set the bar so
high and and I know who you're speaking
about and and that hasn't been brought
up the only time it's been brought up is
with you sir so I I want to talk to that
licensee personally to find out where
we're falling short or where they're in
their minds where we fall short because
I I haven't heard that but I appreciate
your candidness on it and and
representative I appreciate you bringing
that up um you both are not members of
the subcommittee so obviously this is
this issue is way from being solved
because there's a bigger problem
you don't know my problem yet
no it's a bigger problem
it's a real big problem so it might it
might answer your questions
as is pointed out to me by
representative Ammon
that you can only make rules based on
the current statute
so what we would uh I don't know how
this would be but obviously you never
don't take an opinion mostly when it
comes to legislation but in this case we
are asking you to uh keep in mind in
terms of this rule change that uh you
where we would need a statutory change
to make that work
okay
how about that
how about representative did I answer
your question
it's a quick question okay thank you
um uh there's mention of Consulting with
stakeholders in drafting the new rules
uh could that include consultation with
Elizabeth croak's family as
representatives of all those who have
lost family members under these
circumstances so that they know that
their concerns are being addressed
absolutely
and given uh Mr croak David uh who
testified before you
um I had been uh up to the first of the
year because we knew this was coming
down the road
um week weekly probably at the least
every two weeks conversations with him
um during his his daughter's the case
his daughter was a victim of so that
that is common for us to do I I thank
you for acknowledging that we think
that's good business to bring all
stakeholders in involved to get best
practices
okay everybody happy okay uh the motion
representative patusek second by
representative hunt this is just for the
subcommittee members all those in favor
of retaining please raise your hand
one two three four five six
and who am I miss who and I lost
Osborne and okay so it passes six is up
six to zero okay Mr chairman um with
respect to the action that we've that
the subcommittee has just taken
um I presume that this will carry with
the full committee would you
um and if you do this I'm I'm sorry
because I'm I can't read your mind but
would you make sure that representative
Mooney knows what the reason you know
for sure I will be talking to everybody
because we do not mean to be
disrespectful here or put this off no
we're trying to get this right no she
will she will get uh I will give her all
the highlights and lowlights we're
actually Alter Ego okay yeah all right
representative Yemen
just following representative Terry's
comment the governor wrote us a letter
about this bill so we might want to keep
the governor's office informed okay
all right well that was a little more
painful than I thought
okay
um
all right so let's let's
hopefully this one we can do this a
little faster
all right so I want to do right now I
want to do 465.
and I will I I would like to uh make a
motion to retain it
second and um and I will speak to my
motion
okay
um
so this bill is sort of deja vu for me
and that is many years ago we had the
issue of bovine growth hormones uh and
uh in in milk and this is a similar to
pfas was that there was no direct
correlation that that because there was
great hormones you you know it's going
to cause this or that you know that
because that there was something no no
the Food and Drug Administration uh
would had had problems when with trying
to regulate it and do something this
legislature actually over a period of
almost six years had a bill each year
struggling with this issue the end
result was that that
um a uh it was permitted for a built
milk manufacturer to write on their
packaging
bovine growth hormone free
and therefore that too the result was
now consumers can make that choice of
whether they want to buy that product or
not in terms of the bovine growth
hormone and I pretty much I don't I I
don't see anything on packaging I still
see uh bovine growth hormone-free in
packaging okay so I think that we can
solve this issue and because clearly
people don't understand
pfas and how what's going on with pfas
and where what what has pfas in it you
know we've had this bill in another case
in resolution identity bill which is
um that to ban pfas being sold but HHS
says well we don't that's that is a
burden we it's very difficult I mean I
see the guys left the room but he was
here so that it's really hard to do that
so
um what we need to do is figure out a
way to have carpet retailers if that's
that's the focus group we're working on
but it could be expanded to any industry
that has it that to have some way to uh
have them Focus to making sure marketing
wise that they are educating the
consumer that the product is is pfast
free or not representative Sullivan
all right thank you Mr chairman I I
agree with the idea of trying to use the
market to motivate
decision making I think your analogy to
the bovine is not a Perfect Analogy in
that somebody consuming milk with bovine
growth hormone it's in their body and
it's it's just there and I think the
argument here is that there might be a
market failure even in the presence of
this additional information because you
have an externality of
the leachate in the dumps going into
local Waters supplies and I think that's
the the intent of this bill and so I
think
what you're saying might might be a
helpful it would certainly be better
than nothing but I don't think it gets
at the intent of this bill so that's
just my thought but
um I know that this bill has been turned
into that issue I would have to say is
boy
just start saying now we're going to
stop carpets from selling that pfas in
it
the carp I think most people expect
their carpets to last 10 years
so that means they they the result of
that legislation doesn't have an impact
until 10 years from now in terms of
solid waste dump so I would not use that
as a governor on this issue I would
think is more importantly we need to
educate consumers about pfas it might
let them be aware that how Insidious it
is and how where where it is and
therefore make make sure that they're
making choices to to uh ignore it but in
terms of the leech fields and septics
you know in terms of the leech fields
and you know of
landfills
uh you know there's so many other things
that be going in there right there's
mercury in there there's you know all
these other things that are that are
poisonous that are in those Waters so
that's a whole separate issue that
people need to you know the terms of how
we're going to deal with that
leaking of of that which this pfas is
just a drop in the bucket frankly in
terms of all the other things are
leaching in the point of order
represented spear yeah we're this is we
have a motion on the floor to retain
this business this is discussion on on
the bill this is discussion this is only
for the subcommittee uh and this is
actually I believe the ins I had it on
the insurance subcommittee
no business this is the business
subcommittee so I think you're in the
business subcommittee yeah no I just I
thought we should vote I don't want to
we could spend an hour on the merits of
the retaining motion yeah right okay
right so you you you you're okay with
retaining and okay representative spear
the January
as a hazardous substance and or now in
uh negotiations to figure out how
they're going to allow people to sue the
federal government
in a special fund for getting ill from
pfest so the EPA has decided it is a
life-threatening cancer-causing drug
they have found two tests were were
completed this summer linking absolutely
linking pfas to several different kind
of cancers and I can give you the
documentation no I understand that but
all you're doing is arguing why we
should not be passing anything and we
should wait to the EPA to does something
I'm sorry I said anything
we have to try point of order just
letting it go doesn't solve anything
okay reporter should we I think we
should focus on whether we retain the
bill or not right and not have the
hearing again so um
my feeling is that this is so important
to
to do something now not to retain it not
to wait again people are getting sick
they're dying we have evidence of it so
I would like to take this to the floor
to let let the house decide what they
want to do with it and and I as I said
before if this committee comes down 10
to 10 with a vote uh that means we're
sending it with no recommendation and
then we're going to have that circus
that we had yesterday
I guarantee you that's what's going to
happen
okay
so all I'm saying is that if I would
much rather us be the bill doesn't even
have the has an effective date that's
three years out
so if it doesn't really matter whether
we get it out of committee now or versus
getting out of committee in January it's
still long before the effective date I'm
just saying is that wouldn't it be
better if something that we can all
agree on and get behind rather than
having having everybody argue over pfas
for 10 15 half an hour you know back and
forth lay it on the table oh gets pulled
off the table
I mean none of us wait I don't know you
guys but I think it could pass
uh that's fine I'm just saying is that
if if it barely passes like that on this
current do you think you've got the
votes on the Senate side
okay I mean do you think you have the
governor who's gonna you know I'm just
saying that's that
there I understand how important this is
I do understand but at the same time you
have an effective date that's pushed so
far out why are we rushing something
that's only going to be a legislative
Nightmare on the floor uh let alone it's
you know it's just it's basically my
problem is is that we want to send a
good clear message that everybody can
appreciate if this whole idea of that
we've got this 10 10 this this you know
legislature that's so even
to me
yes that means is whatever comes out
whatever happens is going to be ugly
because it's it was
literally voted on by one vote okay I
think you said the two magic words
Senate Governor so
um if you if if there is a commitment
from both sides to really come up with a
solution I could go with retain okay I
mean not just meet 15 minutes in next
yeah absolutely we want to think of
ideas and how we can communicate and get
give it an opportunity for businesses to
to address that you know whether the
pfas is in what they're selling
and that's really it and it's not just
carpets right well we wanted to start
somewhere but again as I said if there's
a commitment to really come up with a
solution then then um and how would we
do that I mean do you would you call
meetings in the summer I mean well we
what I in September we would have a
subcommittee on the bill
and and yeah we were we would be letting
people out give us some ideas on what we
can help New Hampshire businesses and
try to you know address this issue so
that pfas is not being sold in New
Hampshire without the consumer knowing
what they're buying okay
well
I all the more reason why you're in my
mind if California has really banned it
dense Den why would it be sold in New
Hampshire if California banned it yeah
that's that's my point okay all right so
the motion which which subcommittee did
I have this on
business this was the business committee
all right so who's on the business
committee
Ammon Cole Thaxton hunt McAleer Herbert
Julio and Speer
okay
right cool who's out he's here yes
Robert
um
okay
so I have one two three four five six
people are here all those in favor were
retaining please raise your hand
okay then I need to uh appoint
Replacements or every I mean okay so you
don't want to retain it you what do you
want to do with it
we can't pass it in its current form
because I'm saying why would you want to
put that on the floor when you know it's
the bills flawed in it
okay okay
so the vote is to retain those in favor
retaining please raise your hand one two
three four okay those opposed
one two okay it's four to two
okay
all right the last one last but not
least
all right
a house bill 639 all right so I assume
the audiences has plenty of time to read
it over
does anybody have a problem with it so
far or anything that needs to you know
tell us speak now forevermore hold your
peace till it gets to finance and then
you can take it up in finance
yes sir
state your name good morning Mr chair
Timothy Egan chair of New Hampshire can
the trade Advisory Group for the
Cannabis industry uh we're very happy
that there seems to be a lot of
listening being done by this committee
to the effort of State entities to want
to move this bill forward but we did
notice there were two issues that could
avert a well-run
cannabis industry
there seems to be uh any Advisory board
that comes with professional insight
into the industry not in the bill as
well a concern that there are no
caps on the number of licenses one
entity could own therefore restricting
what could be uh individual run Commerce
in the State uh the concern that big
cannabis could come in and take over our
industry those are the two things that
collectively I think were missing there
are probably some minor things that
could be thought about along the way but
unless I'm
not
missing anything else I think I'm
speaking for six or seven or eight
different organizations that have
collectively tried to work together with
you all on this bill those are our two
questions of why they were removed well
I I guess I'll take I'll take the blame
um the two reasons I the the terms of
The Advisory board and the purpose of
Advisory Board
um I I mean I I
adding another level of bureaucracy
um is is one of the things that I I
personally and I think this committee
generally tries to avoid
so in those two issues that would be
Bureau bureaucracy
um and consume in terms of what they're
advising
um I think that the Liquor Commission
when their rules and their rules
hearings they'll have plenty of
opportunity for anybody to come in and
give them advice and and terms of
generating the rules so that there was
no it's just like when we do study
committees do we think commission's a
good idea we have lots of Industry
involved people or do we think it's
better off just having House and Senate
members and then all those people who
care or have an opinion will show up to
that meeting and be able to express
their opinion and it just seems like
it's a more efficient way to run
government
um in terms of the licensing and trying
to control licensing that creates
winners and losers and that is
absolutely an anathema to me and I'm
pretty sure it's anathema to New
Hampshire we we are not in the business
of Taxi medallions you know limiting
licenses and limiting that stuff
um we're we're we actually believe that
if you're going to create something uh
you want to give everybody the equal
opportunity to to get it and I realized
that that might mean there's uh you know
that somebody is going to swallow
everybody up and there's consolidation
in the industry and um but at the end of
the day the New Hampshire way is to is
to allow anybody and everybody to
participate and not and not try to not
not try to pick winners and losers
um my apologies to make sure I was clear
when I was talking about licensing
because it's not a total number of a cap
of licenses but that an individual
business
there's no
control number on the amount that any
one business could own
right well an example I can give you on
that is to take Massachusetts and how we
tried to limit uh uh liquor licenses
and and I guess to the benefit to who
the packies package stores and they said
to grocery stores they started out you
know started out you can only have six
locations then they went to 12. and now
I think they're up to 24. I know they
keep they keep revisiting the issue okay
and so and when it comes uh that to me
that's the the the first the first
mistake was when they put that limit way
back when and to say okay we want to
have Packy Stores
um you know in terms of what uh you know
that New Hampshire's model has always
been we aren't limiting how many
licenses anybody can have because that
inevitably would uh create future
legislation to have to fix that and so
it's better off just being fair up front
and one more comment if I may yes and
that discussion around licenses would
come easier if an Advisory Board existed
because they would be able to assess
what are best practices in the industry
the idea of Advisory Board would be able
to look at neighboring states and the
other 20 some odd states that do have
legal recreational cannabis and an
Advisory Board does not come with fees
and costs while it does come with
Insight it does come with a myriad of
expertise and I think we've I'm trying
to Echo
I guess my
support and answers to questions by
folks in the Senate and in the corner
office about have we studied this
industry and what can we bring to the
table that would make the industry move
smoother and being able to access
experts that are in
cannabis rehabilitative issues
um you know Commerce all the different
facets that the industry touches being
able to give that support to an agency
that is exploring something they've
never explored before could be
beneficial to the state and move our
industry fast I don't know how it could
be any different than alcohol I I the
alcohol is we absolutely there are
plenty of people who think alcohol is a
bad thing and they absolutely have
plenty of opportunity to show up to
rules meetings and and express that your
concerns and so in terms of you know
setting up who's going to be on this
advisory commission that becomes
political in itself
and and that's that you know no we I we
want to avoid that in New Hampshire
personally but maybe other members of
the committee agree with you I don't
know how many other people agree with
you but but I I just think that that in
terms of a product that comes out of
this committee we should be consistent
on what we have always traditionally
believed when it comes to uh that you
know that that no we don't we don't you
know we we don't have an advisory
committee Over The Liquor Commission to
tell them you know how how to address
these issues we have a lobbyist who's
there taking care of that for them okay
so that and yes she's she visits with
the Liquor Commission often and so I I
don't think we need to have a commission
we don't have to have that political
entity uh to to express you know what we
need or shouldn't it be doing
I think we do have them at other
agencies
some are more vocal than others right
okay
not in this committee
not regulated by this committee we have
nobody telling insurance department how
they should be doing insurance we don't
have any we don't have any commissions
on banking we don't have any commission
so so that you know creating a
commission is the mathemat for this
committee
so I'll let your other okay but I
appreciate you coming in and expressing
that so in that way we can tell people
we have heard this concerned and we end
we've like I said at the beginning we do
appreciate that you this your
subcommittee your committee
um Commerce have been listening to all
of the facets of folks interested in
this industry and moving it forward so
we do appreciate fair enough that okay
thank you
is there anybody else who representative
Osborne do you have a comment yeah I'll
just uh comment on this point I I assure
the concern of uh folks from the
industry that they want to be
representative uh represented
my concern though around advisory boards
where you have appointed members though
is those appointees
aren't necessarily representing what
they're supposed to be representing
they're representing uh the people who
appointed them right so I feel like the
industry will be better represented if
they choose their own members to come to
the Liquor Commission to voice their
concerns rather than having someone who
allegedly represents them that may not
necessarily so fair enough
okay yes representative Gibbs thank you
Mr chairman
um this is a question on a different on
a different issue uh this is something
that I noticed in reviewing the February
8th uh version of the amendment I have
not had a chance to review today's
version of the amendment and I want to
make it clear that this is a concern not
a deal breaker for me uh but my question
is I noticed um and this may have been
there in the earlier versions and I just
hadn't noticed it that there were
references to limits on possession and
my question is why if we are legalizing
cannabis uh we're going to put limits on
possession when for instance
um there we have no uh statutory limits
uh or so far as I know regulatory limits
on the number of bottles of liquor that
an individual can possess
so you're saying about this serving size
you you would like to see limits on the
serving sizes no I'm saying why would we
have why would we have limits at all on
the amounts I I uh I think the limit is
at 20 didn't we just ended up was it
what do we end up with
it's at 20 milligrams yeah yeah that
that was that's the high that's so
that's the only limit we have is the
ultimate the high end but yes uh
theoretically the marketplace is free to
make it any sizes that they want it and
my question is why do we need those
limits at all uh
I I uh well given that there was a lot
of political pressure to have more limit
or lower limits it was a balancing of
you know that taking uh taking what's
going on in the marketplace now and the
high the highest that's out there was
the 20 and that's why we we did the 20.
thank you and I believe the atcs are at
20. see atcs it is the ATC at 20 or is
that higher than 20.
there are no limits
um so what representative is talking
about if the personal possession limits
right
is the serving serving size right
two different things okay
that that is that is my question so the
answer to that is we don't want you to
buy so much that you feel compelled to
resell it
reselling we don't want you to come in I
mean it's a sort of it's a reason why
right you know the the uh how the Liquor
Commission got a little hard time
because uh evidently there was a uh a
French uh Courvoisier that was in high
demand and everybody was showing up to
buy it in huge quantities here in New
Hampshire and clearly for the purpose of
reselling it in other states so so the
limits were set up to to ensure to try
to minimize it I wouldn't say it's going
to make it go away because theoretically
those same people come up here with that
truck visit several liquor stores before
they leave the state so they up because
they they have that ten thousand dollar
cash requirement and so they didn't want
to be recorded but uh so I guess that
would be the one Governor we have now is
is nobody wants to hand over ten
thousand and one and then have to be
reported
I remember that that discussion
um
again I just wanted to bring this up yes
no I appreciate you bringing it up
because that was a good question
okay
anything else
all right
who'd like to be representative
um I was as quickly scanning through
this uh version here I know that the one
of the previous versions We had looked
at there was a concern around the sale
of
um water pipes things of that nature
that are not necessarily cannabis
related would would this then turn those
items into cannabis related products
that would be regulated
I do believe that paraphernalia is the
other word we would call it is is
available the key thing was to add The
Vaping making sure we included vaping in
it because that's another paraphernal
device that might be used but I I cannot
imagine that you have a facility selling
marijuana without without
accoutrements that is correct but you
might be selling accoutrement with uh
without selling cannabis right and do we
want to make those people get licenses
all of a sudden because they sell oh
that's the equation yes so uh that
license was added in because it wasn't
somewhat I mean in terms of what the
commission is that there are some very
creative uses of some of that
paraphernal so it's not necessarily the
ones that would be but they are still
barred to sell it to anyone under 21.
so that it could be it could be some uh
device that was a
I mean I guess what was the conversation
we had was what happens if you're one of
these Gift Stores
that you know sells just sells to
tourists and you want to sell something
that might be perceived to be a
marijuana device that that yes we're
going to give them an opportunity to
sell that but but they'll be licensed
and that license will ensure that we'll
make sure that they don't sell it to
someone under 21.
that's why all right okay again so my
concern is the people who exist today so
my my buddy who sells glassware uh is he
now going to have to have a license
because of this uh yeah but the license
could be minimal it's a minimal license
yes if he's selling if he's selling
marijuana you know devices they're the
devices that could be used for remember
proceed to be then he's probably going
to want one of these license so that no
one you know that that he can then
defend his business and not be accused
of being uh an underground marijuana I
have a question yes Representative
Vincent thank you Mr chairman so I just
um just for clarity
um that's taking place today now without
a license right that's taking place now
so now you're saying that we're going to
go ahead and make a license for that we
are going to make a license for that yes
so that again so we can pull it if they
sell to somebody who's under 21.
thank you that's the
excuse me my mic went off that the idea
is to ensure that that we that
if someone is selling something that it
could see that they are have the
potential to sell it to someone under
21. we don't we want them to do it so
theoretically they they could not have
to buy the license it's not like the
liquor enforcement is going to go
knocking on you know go around looking
for people it's more importantly is that
if there was one that then the Liquor
Commission can say that the person did
register and get the license and I
respect that I just think that like for
right now it's already exists it already
happens I know there's a smoke shop or
whatever you want to call it in Dover
New Hampshire
um and uh they are by law I believe and
I don't don't quote me because I really
don't know but I don't think they selled
anybody under 21 if it goes so your
preferences we take this out of the bill
well I just think that just I think it
would be right to take it out of the
bill because I hate to go okay you've
done this for so many years okay now
we're going to give you you need a
license that's fine if you want to take
it out of the bill but Danielle do you
have a comment why it's in there
[Music]
talk to the mic sorry I'm sorry for so
the Cannabis accessories
can automatically be sold by a retail
cannabis
licensee
there's also a provision in the end of
the bill that allows those with a retail
tobacco license to sell cannabis
accessories and paraphernalia
so those that are currently licensed as
a retail tobacco would be grandfathered
and they wouldn't need a new license the
new license carves out the
um individuals or businesses who aren't
currently selling those that want to
start selling those they would then need
a license but for those that are
currently in existence selling the
Cannabis accessories and paraphernalia
who I would say most of them have a
retail tobacco license they're in the
there's a modification to the definition
of the retail tobacco license that would
would allow them to continue selling it
without needing a new license so so if
somebody right now is selling just
glassware
if they're just glassware and they don't
have a retail tobacco then they would
need the cannabis
right so where is that because evidently
we have a move in to take it out of the
bill
so that's the Cannabis accessory
retailer yeah so where's that in the
bill uh that is
um the back looks like the back of these
Pages aren't numbered um back of page
one
but that would only be for those that
are just selling glassware that don't
have a retail cannabis or a retail
tobacco yeah evidently these they don't
want to have a license they don't they
don't want to be required to get a
license so so theoretically they're
never going to sell marijuana
device
they would have a cannabis selling
license right okay so if you're not
selling if it's not for cannabis purpose
then they don't need to get this license
at all right so there's no problem
it's only if they decide they want to
make one or have one that is perceived
to be one is that what you're interested
my concern is so I I would I was in a
fraternity right you can you can smoke
marijuana out of damn near anything
right so I remember apples
I I just don't want people to start
getting in trouble or getting their
business shut down for selling things
that they didn't know they wouldn't they
wouldn't be getting shut down okay all
right
right they're not you're not going to
shut down somebody who's got walking
around with an apple with a whole drill
into it correct okay
I think I'm on the subcommittee yes you
are yeah okay
um
this may be resolved but factoring in
the local that local municipalities can
bar cannabis licenses in their locality
if you need a license to sell glassware
the the local municipality could Trump
your ability to sell the glassware if
we're talking about
licensing under the cap another reason
to remove it is what I'm saying
good cut
if you follow that that
I think that the way this is written
that would be the case that the any type
of cannabis license the municipality
could
could prohibit
so Zone it's a zoning issue then okay so
where where is it in the statute
um I think you'll have to take it out of
a couple places okay
your cannabis accessory retailer
and then it's defined which is defined
and then you'd have to remove
the amendment to the retail tobacco well
do we do we really need to do that
because you still have the tobacco
license so they could be selling their
glassware if they're not selling your
scenario is no marijuana sales are
permitted in Happy Town
but they they're either there or want to
be there there's no provision to deny
them a tobacco license
so they could be there selling their
glassware to go with the tobacco license
which is essentially what's happening
now so that's the the intent of putting
it in those licenses was the original
the original amendment required rules
on cannabis accessories and
paraphernalia there are no there are no
regulations on any of that right now so
if you create rules on them then you
there has to be the ability to regulate
those rules and the only way for us to
regulate the rules is to put them in a
license so if there's going to be no
regulation on cannabis accessories or
paraphernalia then there's no need for
the license types if we want regulation
on the Cannabis accessories
paraphernalia this was the best
structure to do that don't we have the
concern of we need to produce a bill
that's going to be passable
and both houses and signable so I would
rather leave these as well I may find
extra licensing morally reprehensible it
may be a practical reality to to
creating a bill that's everybody can
very majority of people can live with
just my thought
Joe are you saying you think we should
leave it in or
okay
yes representative Vinson thank you Mr
chairman a point of clarification uh I'm
going to use an example so I own a
fireworks store in the state of New
Hampshire file uh Class C fireworks
illegal in the state of New Hampshire in
any City town uh in the state of New
Hampshire the difference is is because
the ordinance for a towns may be
different you may not be able to light
them off in say Dover for example so my
question is this
pot if pass is going to be legal in the
state of New Hampshire so they'll be
able to possess it
even in the towns that don't accept it
you just can't smoke it there correct is
that what is that what we're talking
about here
is that what we're talking about here
that's what I want to know yeah that's
that's what we're talking about no we're
talking about the paraphernalia no I
know I get that but I and I thought we
got past that my question is
pot was legalized in the state of New
Hampshire you can have it in any City in
town you just can't smoke it in certain
ordinances in the city of town correct
well right now you can't sell it either
well I get that but if the bill was
passed it once the bill has passed
there's no no uh the legislation in
terms of dealing with the marijuana
possession is Statewide Statewide so but
I think the extra The Twist is is that I
think there are some towns that pass
zoning that ban marijuana paraphernalia
okay so that that yes they would they
just they're banned Now by putting this
in this bill there's an opportunity
where the town might say okay we don't
have to ban it because they have to just
get this license correct thank you for
that point okay so that might be
a good thing
to stop those towns from
passing those ordinances
are you a member of this committee
no I'm not generally surprised I know
your position on this bill and I'm glad
to have you here I was just confused
still about the glassware thing and I'm
just playing catch up and um coming from
a different committee but uh
so are you telling me
as a committee that the corner store by
my house that has glassware that I'm
confident is not for tobacco use but is
labeled as such right
um that they are currently required to
have a tobacco license no if they don't
sell tobacco they do okay they sell
cigarettes they sell cigarettes so that
means they have the cigarette but they
have a tobacco license and and one of
the things about this bill was that we
have decided because the enforcement of
that is actually the Liquor Commission
so and we didn't change the title of the
Liquor Commission to liquor tobacco when
we did that it's still just Liquor
Commission so that's why we're now
molding the marijuana regulation
enforcement to the same Department the
same Commission
so in this case the issue was what
happens uh it we actually had the
problem with some of the vaping places
that all they sold was vaping
okay and so therefore you know that that
you know in terms of getting the tobacco
license you know that that we require
them to have that tobacco because
because a lot of most establishments
have the have a dual license they have
beer you know liquor beer and wine and
they have tobacco so that most but it's
some some are limited so
um we're we're certainly conscious of
that some businesses are very lean and
mean and are very focused so I guess the
issue is if somebody was selling just
glass devices and then someone walked in
and said boy that sure looks like a
marijuana pipe to me
um that that this person could get cover
by just getting this license that's
going to be what 50 bucks you know the
minimal license but that that it will
then allow them to sell it and that the
commission knows who they are and and
hopefully they will not sell that pipe
to someone under 21.
sure
the intent in the legislation or of this
committee to allow municipalities to
limit the consumption of cannabis just
the sale
no that actually is yeah exactly in
terms of his question we are we're not
regulating the usage all we're
regulating is that the town has the
right to choose whether they'll have a
marijuana retail establishment in their
town
yeah and chairman okay uh representative
M and then I'll come to you Chris
just thinking this through about the
glassware
here's a scenario okay let's say I'm a
glass blower and I'm a I I blow our
Artesian glass okay uh and uh you know
would I need to get a license
uh to continue selling my custom
devices I would say only if you were
marketing it for someone do you sell to
use it for marijuana if you were
changing your marketing strategy you
know Market but a Venetian glass it's a
you're you're selling a very expensive
piece of glass uh glass you know it's
usually a Vaz it's usually glass
drinking wear or something like that
um I don't think you're if you're but if
you were to make a glass pipe which I
think I've seen that in my local
convenience store the marijuana pie if
you're making one of those then yeah
we're asking him to get a license
thank you
okay
to our former member of the Commerce
Committee
oh yeah right excuse me representative
McAlister didn't have a question
um it's thank you not so much the
question but just a clarification if I
understand it uh a town like Dover can
say you can't you can't uh sell
marijuana in the town but they can't
keep somebody from buying marijuana and
coming into Dover but they also I think
the state of the law says you can't
smoke in public regardless yes that's so
and and it's sort of like fireworks uh
my town doesn't allow you to do
fireworks but you can own them you just
gotta you just gotta set them off in
Bartlett
okay
all right so actually I think this was
not a business committee I think I had
this in the liquor committee this is
liquor okay
this should be business
you have a brief comment on the bill as
written absolutely Joe Hannon uh
cannabis accessories I just wanted to
comment that it could be any equipment
products or materials of any kind that
are used intended to use or designed for
use in planting propagating cultivating
does this mean that Lowe's and Home
Depot and any garden supply store is
gonna have to be licensed to sell
potting soil uh heat lamps uh irrigation
this legislation does not
permit home usage this is only retail so
so therefore the licensee if you are a
cultivator
which is sounds like where you were
going with your comments okay cultivator
that if you wanted yes you have to have
a license to be a cultivator
right I mean I'm not talking about being
cultivator but if someone's selling
those products to cultivators or
non-cultivators they're the same
products so it's a person that's selling
it have to how do you differentiate
someone selling those things to a
non-cultivator because the at the end of
the day you're you're not you're not
doing anything to to for marijuana
you're selling a generic product that
can be be used for anything it's the
cultivator is the one that needs to has
the license if he's purchasing it
for purchasing not sales even though the
sales people selling the growing size
you've got to be selling something
that's clearly going to be used for
marijuana
okay and let's face it it's not like the
commission is going to be go into every
business and see what they're doing I
hope not you know it's just it's up all
right thank you representative Osborne
all right one more one more time front
page
at the bottom where it says cannabis
accessories yes it says any equipment
products or materials of any kind that
are used intended for use or designed
for use so it's not just design for use
but are used so if I take this pen cap
and go smoke marijuana out of it
are you as the pen seller now going to
need a license to sell this pen because
I happen to use it one time
for that purpose can we strike this one
word
yeah used
I'm sorry
I used
I think the intended for use
so you just want to take that are
intended for the use yeah intended for
intended or designed for use okay so
just to just delete the word
used used that are like you've got to
make the sentence correct any kind that
are intended for use
our chairman who who drafted this
originally so that the word was used so
just what was that put in there
what was the thing did you guys really
mean to do that we did that Mark who's
with that who put that in there
who put that in
that's from UK oh that's right you're
the one who thought you would really
solve this thing okay see
and you know what she would have been on
your commission
she would have been on your commission
[Laughter]
so in short Mr chairman we're hearing
that this was a mistake yes yeah right
she didn't she didn't intend that's the
word okay the word should not be there
okay
all right so we we will call that a uh
unintended uh error uh a minor a minor
Amendment but that does mean we'll have
to reprint all of these things for
everybody
but that's okay all right so
um
so we're gonna representative putusic
second by representative Burroughs
moves um ought to pass on the amendment
uh
oh five three oh with
the delete
of use
it will have a new number yeah the bill
will have a new number okay
yeah well that unfortunately that
changes randomly changes often so we're
careful about doing that so normally I
would just say Roman numeral three the
under the definition of cannabis so
cannabis accessories excuse me okay is
the question clear so now we're looking
for just uh to the committee is
fine Osborne Burrows Sullivan Collier
and Vincent okay everybody clear all
those in favor raise your hands one two
three four five six all those opposed
six to one okay
all right and uh all those opposed to
ought to pass as amended
put too sick
saying my Burrows
okay all those in favor as amended right
raise your hand
two three four five six and those
opposed
okay
next to one all right we're
subcommittee is now over
okay so we'll yeah well one 115.
the one it's what I have in here
okay
[Music]
pull out the screen
okay or are you taking aluminum foil
yeah
foreign
and
that anybody like a discussion on why
we're retaining it
I think we'd be
good
so I I would say I did see uh
representative Mooney uh downstairs for
lunch and explained to her uh what
happened and uh and I told her watch the
tape watch the Youtube
um but uh but we're we're confident that
the Liquor Commission will resolve it
um uh in a way that that uh he when my
uh follow-up just let you all know the
follow-up conversation I had with them
about rules is that
that
um
the statute talks about the five
thousand
uh the the top ends but the idea of
adding in this uh 30-day uh mandatory
for employees who don't are not trained
she said that would not necessarily
require a statutory change that they
could do that by rule but as I would at
some point in time I would say we
probably still would want to put it in
the Statue we would whatever they do
with the rules with the penalties I
think should should ultimately be in in
the statute just so so it's easier for
people to follow because I I've actually
been people complain about how much
rules are going on how rule making I
always said that um and obviously now
I'm going to date myself but way back
when it didn't happen when I was here I
was probably having my freshman year
that every Department actually expired
and that it uh they had to be re-upped
for every Department would ever say
agency and uh and I always said well we
should do that with rules that that at
times when we pass legislation and we
said okay we will give rulemaking for
this rulemaking for that I always
thought that those rules should then
come after they're all done and
implemented then they should come back
to us and put in a statute so
representative Gibbs you want to make a
comment on that thank you Mr chairman
German
I was a director of a state agency
during that period it was called the
sunset the sunset and my agency the New
Hampshire Human Rights Commission was in
the first Sunset round and we had the
Good Fortune to be in The Last Sunset
right
that law was repealed because it was
found to be completely wasteful it did
nothing useful and from my experience
having had the enjoyable experience of
two rounds I can tell you for sure it
was completely wasteful
but I was getting to the but the idea
that rules should come back and and be
installed and such because we're not
into the minutia especially you take the
what we've done with 639 how much
rulemaking is going on with that that at
some point in time you think wouldn't it
be better that after the rules were
implemented that had then come back to
us and then be put in the statute so so
it's kind of one stop shopping when
you're looking to know what the law is
Mr chairman if we're gonna if we're
taking us in the way back machine to
that time when you made that suggestion
I'm curious to know how is that received
uh did you get an offer of extra credits
on your easy
um well there's a lot of wonderful ideas
I have but that didn't go very far like
that if we were to have a if we were
going to do casinos we should have a
state casino and I wanted to put it in
Salem Windham right in between the
highways whereas they've now taken that
away because they expanded the highway
through that area but I thought we
should have a state casino that the only
way you could get in or out of it is
from the highway but that's another idea
actually I did have some lobbyists
thought that you know that was a good
idea but it didn't get president okay so
the motion is to retain any more
discussion on the motion see none the
clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon that's me I vote
Yes representative Osborne yes
representative
representative Terry yes representative
post
yes representative aikenberg yes
representative Porcelli yes
representative Thaxton
representative Walsh yes
representative Burroughs
representative Herbert
representative Howard yes
representative McAleer yes
Representative Vincent Yes
representative Calabro yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Gibbs yes
representative Speer
yes
representative Sullivan
and representative hunt yes 20-0 all
those in favor placing on the consent
Calendar please say aye
those opposed so moved unanimously
okay next up is uh uh House Bill three
seventy three
restricting the use of pfas substances
and consumer products
and
oh
this is
oh Ambulance Service oh that was still
hanging out there okay no wonder I was
going to say this looks like it's done
wrong but okay okay House Bill 370c uh
relative to building for ambulance
services and we want to and I make a
motion to retain yes representative
Burroughs
second by representative patusek moves
to retain 373.
any discussion on the retaining motion
okay
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon votes yes
representative Osborne yes
representative two sick yes
representative Terry yes representative
post representative inkenberg yes
representative Porcelli yes
representative thackson representative
Walsh yes representative Burroughs
representative Herbert yeah
representative Howard
representative McAleer yes
Representative Vincent Yes
representative Calabro yes
representative Bolden yes representative
Gibbs yes representative Speer yes
representative Sullivan
and chairman hunt yes 20-0 all those in
favor placing on the consent Calendar
please say aye
no suppose she'll move nemlessly now we
can get to HP 465.
pfas
so I will move
and representative patusa will second to
retain 465.
is there a need for discussion or are we
okay
Anita
okay okay okay so the motion is to
retain 465.
clerk will call the roll
thank you
but I made the motion and oh
representative Ammon votes yes
representative Osborne yes
representative yes representative Terry
yes representative post yes
representative eikenberg yes
representative Porcelli yes
representative Thaxton
representative Walsh yes
representative Burroughs
representative Herbert no
representative Howard yes
representative McAleer no
Representative Vincent Yes
representative Calabro yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Gibbs yes representative
Speer yes on the protest
representative Sullivan
and chairman hunts yes 18-2 18-2
okay
I forgot retain doesn't it doesn't have
consent calendar under what I was
thinking okay
not only the old days when I used to be
just the chair could say I have a sense
but
no there is no blur with fruit retaining
there's no butter
okay uh last but not least uh House Bill
um so it is actually uh the legislative
Services is working on it
normally we don't vote on anything
without having it in front of us so we
could do one of two things we could uh
waive that rule and I could certainly
review all the changes that we're making
wait till after we've had our hearings
and take it up later today
Representative Vincent make a motion to
waive the rules okay
all right all those in favor and waving
the rules say yes
uh those opposed
okay so
um since I gave my version away I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this by memory on the
first page
down where is the Cannabis uh
paraphernalia
definition
excuse me yeah accessories in
paraphernalia we're going to remove on
line 28 the word used
page eight
it was line 19.
um
I don't even know if kanana bin is a
word or not but is going to be cannabis
potency representations
so on line 19 on page 8 it says the
testing shall also verify THC and other
canaanabin potency representations for
correct labeling cannabin well the N
will be dropped and will be replaced
with an s
cannabis
and then on page 11
um they
um online well it's it's F10 licensure
procedures for cannabis establishment
uh no no it's not it excuse me
uh 12. if 318 F9 Roman numeral two
says the proposal shall include a plan
to allow the Cannabis retail stores to
obtain a therapeutic cannabis
endorsement that will allow them to
serve qualified patients without
imposing
the meals cannabis and rooms tax
well that since we now have removed
the rooms and meals tax let alone we're
really going to change the rooms of
military camps oh my God thank God we
removed this line okay so what that is
going to replace is uh
uh no I don't remember but it's going to
basically refer to the RSA that has the
excise tax which is only paid by the
um
Mr chairman which line is this so this
is line
14.
it starts on 13 where it says imposing
okay
so
the bills cannabis and room sacks so
So Adam what was the what is the rep
page was the reference to then it was to
uh
where's the actual tax that we remember
I had it I had my finger on it the last
time but I forgot
so anyways we we only have one tax
and the tax is going to be done at the
cultivator level
and so that will refer to that RSA
in here somewhere
okay so we get surprised we can find it
first
okay so those are the only three changes
that legislative Services is working on
and doing it
um I would say that this bill has a long
way to go
there'll be plenty of chances for
eyeballs to eye things and and
um
who knows what it's going to look like
on the back end but
so is there any other discussion on the
changes yep are they working on this
right now will they have it done by the
time we're done I I would assume that it
would be done by the end of the day yes
we would have it at the end of the day
but we've waived the rule that we'll
vote go ahead and vote for it now okay
we have an amendment number no we don't
so that that amendment number will be
written in when it when we get it okay
any more discussion on the motion yes
representative procedural questions you
just mentioned there will be
opportunities for changes can you as a
first time rep can you please explain
articulate all the opportunities okay so
let's say between between now and
Wednesday Thursday when this when we
have uh the floor session
if it comes out that something is
obvious then we would do a floor
Amendment
and that and I would have representative
Burroughs and I would make a floor
amendment to that change once uh then it
goes on to finance
uh finance committee has an opportunity
to do whatever they want with this bill
and and obviously if there's some
Amendment comes up that needs to be
changed it could be done as an amendment
in the finance committee and then they
too would have the same procedure
waiting for hit the house floor if they
something is not correct it can be fixed
in the housework
so that would make it get it out of the
house then then it's over to the Senate
and who knows what the Senate May do
with it
steps yes
can Finance change anything in it or
just relative to the finance how many
years have you been arrested not enough
okay so that's always been a
um a uh I'd say
a the rub because the assumption is that
when it goes to the second committee
they should narrow their discussion to
just that subject matter in which they
have authority so it was not a dumb
question
but no I didn't say it was a dumb
question I said it was a dumb question
okay no no I was saying is how many
years have been have you heard this
debate before about did did Finance
really focus or ways and me's do they
really just focus or did they feel free
because in past years this marijuana
bill has always gone through Ways and
Means and and Lord knows they were going
on beyond their subject tests
um so
anyway so no it's not a dumb question
it's just it's one of those
those things that are hanging around for
years and years we've had
thank God your mic was turned off
okay any more discussion on the motion
okay so representative uh so who wants
to make the motion who wants to write
the blurb on this one
okay representative Thaxton
seconded by
represent
per house
moves
ought to pass on the amendment that we
don't have a number yet but
any discussion on that motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative admin votes yes
representative Osborne yes
representative tusek yes representative
Terry
yes representative post yes
representative aikenberg yes
representative Porcelli
voting on the amendment yes
representative Thaxton
representative Walsh
no
representative Burroughs
representative Herbert
representative Howard
yes representative McAleer yes
Representative Vincent Yes
representative Calabro yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Gibbs yes
representative Speer yes
representative Sullivan
chairman hunt yes 19-1
okay now the motion is by representative
Thaxton second by representative
Burroughs moves ought to pass as amended
any discussion on the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
representative Ammon votes yes
representative Osborne yes
representative batusic yes
representative Terry no
representative post yes
representative aikenberg yes
representative Porcelli
representative Thaxton
representative Walsh no
representative Burroughs yes
representative Herbert
representative Howard yes
representative McAleer yes
Representative Vincent Yes
representative Calabro yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Gibbs yes
representative spear yes
representative Sullivan
chairman hunts yes
17-3 okay we will leave that on the
regular calendar and uh
so I need that blurb done
right now
and Minority Report and would there be a
Minority Report
if somebody helps me write one sure I
mean I've never done one
okay so just if you're gonna do it
remember what I had to have it done
today
so you gotta you gotta whip it up and
your motion would be itls soon right
and and you need to make a motion you
have to make a motion what would your
motion be
yes my motion would be to itl
okay and then the other two yeah because
well we retain retain we don't need the
blurbs yeah retain yeah they're all
retained okay all right with that we are
out of exact session
and
foreign
that's
fine
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
House Bill 513 and hear from the prime
sponsor representative thank you and
welcome back to the Commerce Committee
thank you Mr chairman
members of the member of the committee
it's great to be back in the house
Commerce Committee after a few years
this is where I started my legislative
career about 20 some years ago
and learn from your esteemed chairman
you're all very lucky to be here and I'm
lucky to be back so I thank you very
much for your kindness this afternoon
and you're scheduling accommodations to
hear both bills
of mine in one afternoon
so I'll give you a little bit of a quick
background
I was a young paramedic
uh working on patient safety and
resuscitating patients when I first
joined the Commerce Committee I think
back in about 1996
and I learned from this committee about
making Health Care efficient and
practical
and managing health care costs and
various aspects of insurance then I went
off back into business for 20 some years
before rejoining the legislature this
term
so a little bit of background we all
think pbms are a very health helpful
part in managing health care costs and
Pharmacy costs
and I think we should understand a
little bit about how the industry's
evolved in 2011 there were seven major
Pharmacy benefits managers
by 2015 just four years later there were
just four
and then by 2022 Express Scripts OptumRx
and CVS Caremark held 80 percent
of the market the pharmacy benefits
management business
Insurance payers like Aetna are owned by
CBS CVS owns CVS Caremark
Cigna owns Express Scripts UnitedHealth
owns OptumRx
it's a little important to understand
some of those relationships and the
potential for inherent conflicts when we
Endeavor to put the patient first
and understand who is billing and who is
paying who
so I think it's just important that we
kind of have that little bit of contact
context
when we think about the patient
affordability
and the safety of clinician-administered
drugs I just want to put that a little
bit into context because we do like
efficiency in health care in New
Hampshire and we like affordability
when we evaluate health plans and how to
maximize our health care dollar across
the Continuum of Health Care
so that's what I'm trying to do with a
relatively simple Bill about patient
safety and about optimizing and reducing
the cost of certain types of medication
delivery under Pharmacy benefits versus
medical benefits and I hope you'll all
help me do that here on a with this bill
that we've worked on for a number of
months before it got to this point
so this bill aims to address a little
known and sometimes not well understood
practice of health plans and Pharmacy
benefit plans known as white bagging and
brown bagging
seems like an odd odd term a number of
states have taken a look at this some
have enacted legislation some have not
and many are considering it right now in
this legislative term
while initially and sometimes
well-intended and useful these practices
can often and occasionally be harmful
and dangerous
to certain patients especially cancer
patients I'm sure everybody here has
been touched by a cancer patient
hopefully none of you will be personally
these patients are high volume users of
infusion treatments like chemotherapy
I'm sure you've all heard of
chemotherapy these drugs are
administered generally by IV infusions
at an infusion center
this is where white bagging comes into
play
so I know you know what a brown bag
lunch is probably packed one of taken it
to school
right well white bagging is when the
medication is shipped by your Pharmacy
Benefit Plan
to the infusion center in advance of
your treatment
sorry
okay hope I wasn't out of order already
I just barely got here I just had to
move into the space Oh okay welcome
anyhow so white banking is when you are
when you arrive to your effusion
treatment and your infusion uh therapy
has been shipped ahead of you
um
and the patient gets there and finds the
treatment has been shipped ahead of them
Brown bagging is when that infusion is
shipped to the patient's home and the
patient is required to bring it with
them to the treatment center
so you probably have already figured out
that brown bagging has some inherent
risk
anybody had a problem with I don't know
an Amazon delivery maybe not making it
there on time or a Last Mile courier
delivery service if you know what
LaserShip have you ever had a tracking
number that started with ls that's a
LaserShip
they're right out of Woburn their last
mile delivery Courier Service
if you've ever had a blue apron shipment
get spoiled on you
um or any other last mile Courier
Service so some of those things or if
you're just stressed managing you or
your loved ones cancer treatment and
you've got enough on your mind and you
maybe aren't expecting your infusion
treatment to arrive that particular day
you went away for the weekend took a
long weekend or something like that now
you may hear that there are some
controls in place and there are that's
true but nothing's perfect nothing's
perfect but it's when your when it's
your cancer treatment or your loved
one's cancer treatment you know what I
want my chemotherapy drug
and that treatment and that standard of
care to be perfect
I want it to arrive on time when it's
supposed to be on time and I don't want
to hear the guy on the other end of the
LaserShip or whoever any Courier to tell
me it was a weather delay or it
shouldn't have arrived in July and sat
on the porch I really don't want any
excuses
right so I don't want Brown bagging to
happen and I least of all don't want it
to be imposed upon me because it's a
cost-saving measure under any
circumstances
That's My Philosophy when it comes to
patient safety and affordability in New
Hampshire when it comes to cancer
treatment patients and it's not just
cancer
there's a number of different types of
infusion therapy where Brown bagging
applies
point of clarification
you want white bagging right is that
what you want so there are two types of
you said Brown bagging there's two types
of of issues of practices that this
legislation addresses Brown bagging and
white bagging I understand and in
section three of the bill which I'm
going to get to so if you bear with me I
will get to it to Representative Vincent
I will represent Vincent right sorry
representative okay thank you placards
right I will get to it uh White bagging
and brown bagging are both addressed and
actually Brown bagging there is still a
carve out if the patient and the
provider both consent to it and there's
a couple ways we can deal with it in the
current language the current Amendment
replaces all after the enacting Clause
that you got today allows for the
patient and the prescriber to consent to
it there are a couple limited cases
where you may still want actually Brown
bagging a rural case and an informed
patient like so let's say I'm fairly
knowledgeable
I've been a healthy been in healthcare a
while and I may be on the lookout and I
may need that to be shipped to my house
for a couple of reasons right so we may
still want to allow that and that's the
New Hampshire way consent knowledgeable
right but I would not want it to happen
for a non-knowledgeable patient and I
wouldn't want it to be imposed upon you
I want it to be your choice right
Freedom of Choice that's a good thing
that's New Hampshire right
so but in in general
um the this bill addresses both white
bagging and brown bagging for white
bagging we would like I would I think in
general it's a good idea if we do it and
we avoid the proverbial 600 aspirin we
Bill we have the the plans bill under
the more economical Pharmacy benefit as
opposed to the medical benefit the 600
aspirin and I'm gonna get to that too
okay
um so the the safe the unsafe and
impractical problems are created in uh
the the brown bagging and sometimes in
white bagging so let me get back to the
white bagging situation where it can be
safe and improv unsafe and impractical
here in Concord just Concord for example
the conquered Cancer Treatment Center
the practice is you arrive for your
chemotherapy infusion treatment your
Pharmacy has sent white bag has sent it
in advance
and
you show up your oncologist orders labs
who hasn't heard of this practice you
show up get Labs ordered you have your
white count checked your liver function
checked your kidney function checked and
today your labs are a little bit off
so your medical oncologist decides you
need a slightly different mix than what
was ordered
so he orders a different cocktail
now they go and check what's arrived and
it's not quite the right cocktail you
have two options
allow your tumor to grow inside you
another week while they ship you another
cocktail or
right you get the idea
there's different types
of cancer therapy sometimes you get
chemo
say for triple negative breast cancer
standard of care may be to have chemo
first before surgery shrink the tumor
first before they go in and take it out
sometimes you have chemotherapy after
surgery right it depends it's a there's
very specialized types of cancer
treatment it all depends so imagine
you're faced with that decision to make
your oncologist is faced with that
decision to make use what they sent you
or wait a week
right these are very difficult decisions
to make and I've known plenty you know
not not as in my family but outside of
my family everybody knows somebody who's
gone through chemo right I'm sure
everybody around this table has so
anyways you get the idea these are
challenging decisions and that's what
this bill aims to address but even more
importantly I mean maybe not arguably
not more importantly than the safety
issue it's the waste that's generated
now you've got this expensive drug
that's going to go in the bin
that costs all of us money the Whole
Health Care System money that diverts
that's why we have to do something now I
know there's going to be discussion
about retaining this bill work on it you
know uh maybe change a little bit of
language about an opt-in practice here
it's another amendment I was handed by
one of the interested parties and
actually it's a good it's a it's a good
Amendment but it's a small one and I
think we can probably take care of this
if the committee is of a mind we can
work together and probably get a bill
out so anyways I I can go on and talk a
little bit about the fiscal note
methodology
um
I'm going to talk about some more of the
affordability aspect
but I'm just going to sum it up and and
thank you uh for your care and transport
of this bill to the house floor uh
sometime fairly soon there's some some
vital issues to be addressed and I think
we can do it and I want to just take
some of your questions because I think
you probably have a few
okay we do have a question
representative Vinson thank you Mr
chairman thanks again for taking my
question so um
so this whole white bagging Brown
bagging it doesn't apply to all
hospitals because I'm pretty sure I have
a good friend of mine and his wife works
at Wentworth Douglas and they actually
make their own cocktails there is that
true
um that's very very possible they it is
definitely possible that they may make
their own the question is what do they
charge for those and do they bill under
the medical benefit the 600 aspirin
potentially or do they build under the
pharmacy benefit this bill will
um uh require that they bill under the
most efficient way and that's the
language that you see
in uh uh section
two it's a line 15 of the amendment
right you should have the amendment
0532h
section two
starting line 15 A and B so that's what
requires them to bill in the most
efficient manner right so under Pharmacy
benefit versus medical benefit so we do
want them
to mix their own custom cocktail that's
exactly what they do over here right
here in Concord
um and and many for the standard of care
they mix their own custom they check the
labs mix it you know soup du jour if you
will right sure
and that's the best best practice we
want that to happen thank you
representative spear
so in the cases where the billing
is done under the medical benefit who
makes that decision as to how it gets
billed ah thank you for your question
that's a great question uh it is the
folks who are at the top of that billing
food chain and would very much like to
maximize the profits of that hospital so
the question might be you might be
wondering who loses in this in this bill
um and that's also a good good question
and they're definitely
um
the hospital the hospitals the hospitals
might might be
uh suffering a bit of a
refocus of their profit model on this
because they're not going to be allowed
to Bill 600 for an aspirin
for the question you may inquire
uh
how did the pbms do they get a better
rebate as a result of going through the
medical or do they are they ambivalent
to the whole thing
well I'm sure you're going to hear from
some of them and
several of their government relations
folks assisted with the crafting and
recrafting and recrafting of this
language
representative petusic thank you Mr
chairman I have would you believe would
you believe representative that there
are a myriad of other illnesses that are
covered by this as a matter of fact a
friend of mine is an MS patient and that
person gets infusions so I'd just like
everybody know that it's not just cancer
patients it's a myriad of other
illnesses that utilize this therapy
thank you representative professional
petusic thank you so much for that that
question and I would definitely believe
that in fact I skipped over it I
shortened my my written testimony not
only are cancer patient effectives but
so are a multitude of other diseases
like rheumatoid arthritis other
autoimmune other other autoimmune
conditions in fact you have in front of
you written testimony uh from uh the
long crso they submitted written
testimony their president and their
physician uh Center for rheumatoid State
organizations and their New Hampshire
chapter submitted written testimony in
support of the bill
great thank you very much
okay uh so this this is yeah
Kathy Bizarro thank you so much
and then uh it says Tanya Carlton is
also coming up and what's New Hampshire
SHP
okay New Hampshire Society of Health
Health Systems you know no s right
Health Systems pharmacists okay
Cassie
kept looking for you Cassie but you had
that mask on and you were hiding back
there and I said I know what Kathy looks
like I I've known her for years
representing the hospital Association
thank you good afternoon
Mr all of our 26 uh Community Hospitals
do you mind taking your mask off or is
it really
yeah and may I request just testifying
because we can't any request that you
speak a little slower
yeah sure thank you
we have we're very picky here right no
matter speak slowly
into the mic and what I then pull the
mic towards you okay are we good we'll
soon find out okay start again I can
start again
um for the record my name is Kathy
Bizarro thundberg Executive Vice
President New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all 26 acute
care hospitals and Specialty hospitals
in New Hampshire with me is Tanya
Carlton and I'll have her introduce
herself
so good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Tanya Carlton I am the president-elect
for the New Hampshire Society of Health
System pharmacists which represents all
pharmacists that work in the hospitals
throughout the state of New Hampshire
and Tanya is here to be the subject
matter expert as a practicing pharmacist
and working in a health system so if we
do receive questions certainly I can um
pass them on to Tanya
um for the record the New Hampshire
Hospital Association is not taking a
position on House Bill 513 right now
however we believe it is important to
provide background and education on this
topic to this committee as hospitals are
impacted by the policies raised in this
legislation it is not completely clear
to us what the sponsor was attempting to
do with House Bill 513 what we believe
he was trying to address something
called Brown bagging of specialized
Pharmaceuticals I did hear his testimony
as the sponsor of the bill also saying
it was related to White bagging we're
not clear how it applies to both but um
what we're going to do here today is to
provide background information about
both those practices
and he also testified that appears the
bill would change reimbursement
processes for how specialized
Pharmaceuticals are billed to insurance
companies but again the language was
unclear he did share a copy of his
Amendment with us right before the
hearing so we have not had a chance to
take a look at the impact of the what
that Amendment could do
we do appreciate that the sponsor has
raised such an important policy topic
which is how insurance companies are
modifying access to specialized drugs
which could negatively impact both
patients and providers and here's the
background on those practices
white bagging and brown bagging are
insurer created practices that
circumvent proper federal and state
requirements for drug management drug
inventories and Drug waste handling
white bagging is when the insurer orders
drugs from their own Specialty Pharmacy
sends it to a hospital or provider
where the patient receives their
medication
Brown bagging is when the insurer orders
drugs from their own Specialty Pharmacy
and sends it to the patient's home and
makes the patient bring that medication
to the hospital or provider for an
Administration in a health care setting
we at the hospital Association have
learned of many many patient experiences
from our member hospitals where insurer
required white bagging and brown bagging
practices have caused delays in
treatment due to drugs not arriving on
time
wrong drugs being delivered or the
hospital pharmacist not being able to
verify that the drugs were kept at
proper temperatures throughout the
entire shipping process
the insurers contend that white bagging
and brown bagging save money
it's our position that this practice May
save money for them but not for their
members who are subjected to canceled
appointments missed work and missed
critical treatments because their
insurer Supply drugs didn't arrive on
time were simply the wrong medication
for the patient or were damaged in
shipment
it also costs the Health Care System
money in handling drugs that are not
part of their own inventory due to the
fact that they have to store them and
waste them if the wrong drugs were
shipped
hmm
in many cases patients must have lab
work done on the day of their treatments
especially cancer patients that will
translate to very specific drug
requirements that get prepared that day
all of which means that white bagging
and brown bagging can't be used because
those drugs have made up several days in
advance
the growth in specialty pharmacies is
driven by insurance companies and not
hospitals only one Hospital in New
Hampshire manages a specialty pharmacy
that Specialty Pharmacy integrates
pharmacists with providers into Clinic
sites which means that access to
medications is provided in real time to
optimize proper dosages and Therapies
some insurers own their own specialty
pharmacies and are requiring their use
by their members and the health care
providers in their Networks
another Trend we see nationally are that
insurers are moving prescription drug
costs from medical benefit to a
prescription drug benefit as we have all
seen members are paying more out of
pocket because prescription drugs paid
under a pharmacy drug benefit typically
have higher deductibles and co-pays
the tension that exists between
healthcare providers in the insurance
industry concerning the provision of
Highly specialized medications is
significant the hospitals and health
care providers are focused on the
delivery of the highest quality of care
and the safest manner possible while the
insurance industry is primarily focused
on the cost of those drugs
I've attached a document to my testimony
that helps explain the white backing
practice in more detail the schematic
clearly illustrates the ways in which
white bagging interrupts the flow of
quality patient care
well I don't have a schematic specific
to Brown bagging it would be very
similar except that the insurance
company sends the medications to the
patient's home and requires the patient
to bring those medications to their
provider
to be clear the hospitals are advocating
that brown bagging medications should be
prohibited
white backing medications should be
prohibited when dosage and or
compounding are dependent upon current
patient lab results or clinical
presentations at the time of medication
administration
white begging medications should only be
considered when quality and safety
criteria are met and mutually agreed
upon standards are applied including
that the joint decision between the
provider and the payer that a white
bagging medication is in the best
interest of the patient
House Bill 513 while it appears to
tackle some of our concerns about Brown
bagging doesn't go far enough and may
even complicate situations with how
Brown bagging could be used and then how
it's paid for
due to the complexity of this important
topic we are unsure that house bill 513
is the right vehicle to properly address
this practice
we hope that this information is helpful
to you and we're very open for questions
thank you
thank you Hillary Clinton collabro
um I guess
I wasn't really clear about the
intention behind the bill and as
somebody who's ordered both Brown and
and what and I can justify this having
ordered both for my patients so I I
guess I didn't really understand what it
was that we were trying to control and
my guess was that we were trying to I
guess I'm asking are we trying to
control the billing
rate in which we are getting P's for
service like we're going to do it
through the farm benefit rather than the
medical benefit
I guess I don't understand
what
yeah
representative we also didn't understand
the language of the bill to be able to I
think you would have to ask the sponsor
what the true we will take it up in
subcommittee I appreciate it I
appreciate it thank you thank you okay
any
representative spear
so I understand what you're saying uh
but in the cases where I mean how many
hospitals could actually compound or
make the drug that might be needed I
mean is that so white begging may not be
totally eliminated right or can you
always generate it or whatever
yes so
many hospitals have started to move in
the direction where they are they have
policies or are trying to eliminate
white bagging
hospitals have formularies in which they
have certain medications of what they
can administer so
we do our best to try to go through the
insurance companies to
ensure we have the appropriate prior
approvals to get the medication that's
best that is able to treat the patient
in the setting I know there was a
question earlier about white bagging and
whether or not it's happening at local
hospitals it does happen at local
hospitals and so the medication is
is sent to the hospital and then the
hospital has it in an inventory we need
to make sure that it is stored
appropriately and then the pharmacy
personnel
ensures that it meets the criteria for
the patient to receive it but prepares
that medication as well
for the patient and so I think what your
question was sorry if I went a little
sideways there was
can hospitals provide the medications to
the patients absolutely follow one for
the question may inquire thank you so
much
I'm lost
but if you're getting the medications
wouldn't you have the same problem about
uh making sure they get to you in the
right condition like how do you know
that the mailing or whatever that
they're sending do you test it or
anything we don't that's why
um
you know the national organizations
such as ashp and American Hospital
Association also are not supportive of
white bagging because they could get
left on a loading dock it could be
you know left out in the Heat or the
cold or it may not be delivered in time
so there's many examples that I have
where the medication never made it to
the hospital and so therefore the
decision is made do you use your own the
medication from the hospital supply or
do you turn that patient away
representative post
thank you Mr chair so my question is if
the hospital
are against this
how are the patients getting it through
the mail they must be ordering it for
them to go to their home so not every
single Hospital have policies and
procedures against Brown bagging white
bagging many hospitals do allow it to
occur however because of the risks
associated with the quality control of
the medication many hospitals are
starting to move away from this practice
because we just can't ensure that the
medication
has been through the right quality
control
a follow-up for the question we inquire
yes so so if that's the case
um where uh the medicines are are going
to the people and and coming in has
there been any study or any
um statistics of how many of these drugs
have caused a problem once they've you
know brought it back into the hospital
is that what's creating this I think
what's creating it is not necessarily
that we've necessarily I haven't seen
any studies looking at that specifically
but what we might see is a delay in
patient care right because the usually
we have
the providers like if they see any
discoloration of the medication or any
breakdown of the medication they're not
going to administer that medication and
so therefore there may be a delay in the
patient receiving treatment
one more follow-up so
you already said in the hospital
sometimes things go wrong would you say
there's more instance of it going wrong
with patients who have brought it in
then again is there any
comparison and that we could look at to
see so I would say both practices
have their inherent issues right but if
something is white bagged at least there
is some control once it does get to the
hospital pharmacy
we have no control over what the patient
does with it right
we don't know it could be stored in
their glove compartment for five days
representative Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman there was mention
in the testimony that this bill might
actually complicate the problems of
brown bagging and white begging and that
this bill might not be the best
um way of solving the problems could you
tell us how this bill might complicate
the problems and what you would propose
as an alternative
thank you for the question
um when we first read the bill it
appeared as if it was only focused on
Brown bagging but then it was
um not exactly clear
from at least our perspective that It
ultimately would apply to all brown
bagging and then when we heard the
sponsor say that it applied to both
white and brown bagging two different
types of scenarios
again I question how that could be so I
think we're going to have to look at the
language very clear clearly I think the
other aspect of the bill
um at least from the billing side of it
looked like it was only modifying the
Managed Care
Insurance statutes and insurance covers
more than just the Managed Care statute
so I think there were several aspects to
it that would have to be evaluated
further question may inquire thank you
can you tell us what you would propose
as an alternative
it sounds like this is going to
subcommittee so I think that we could
certainly you know come up with some
suggestions and ideas clearly you know
we know from the hospital's perspective
that we think Brown bagging should be
outright outright uh prohibited and only
white bagging for limited circumstances
so we'd have to look very closely at
that thank you
I'm sorry I I I'm gonna weigh in because
I have a question and I've been
patiently waiting
so
this issue of
the firm is the hospital pharmacy
charging 400 400 percent more
than I guess an in-network that I see in
in the pairs preferred provider Pharmacy
provider is this true
are you guys really charging more just
because you're a hospital
so each Hospital right there's a there's
a lot going on right now with price
transparency at hospitals so each
hospitals have their own charge master
in terms of what they do charge and so
um
there are limited things in the hospital
that rev you know in order to keep the
lights on in many hospitals right now
are really struggling right this is a
profit Center well no it's not but
there's the other things that we do
charge for right and so I wouldn't say
we're up charging anything by 400 okay
so but are you a provider are are you
signing the contracts with the insurance
company as a preferred as a pharmacy and
agree to their pricing their their pbm's
demand on what the price should be right
so hospitals do have contacts with their
insurers so I am sure the insurers are
not signing a contract for a 600 aspirin
so I think again there's some language
issues here they're um whether they
charge for something versus what they
actually get paid are very different
things
and guaranteed the insurers pay a lot
less
well I understand that part but I'm just
wondering that you know we that being a
a preferred Pharmacy provider if I'm
reading the words here okay that
assuming that that PBM has lined you as
the pharmacies have a contract so the
pharmacies know full well that they're
not going to get what they bill for is
it true that you're billing on a
different billing code to get around
this so that you're not paying what it
would have been I mean let me put this
way the only read brownbacking exists is
because it seems to be a hell of a lot
cheaper than what you would build
so the insurance companies do have
contracts with the hospitals and other
providers not just hospitals to do
infusion
it's up to the contract negotiations on
what they ultimately will accept for
payment with the insurance companies so
it's very well known by the insurance
companies what is available for billing
and for payments
so there shouldn't be any surprises okay
now representative Terry
so I'm looking at the the handout and
I'm seeing that the material on the
that's that's printed in Orange compared
to the material that's pretty uh
presented in green uh appears to at
least appears to suggest a more uh
complicated or convoluted and lengthier
process
the green looks like a more streamlined
so if you could uh it's part one address
whether that's accurate in terms of the
description the presentation and my
surmisel of what this means or
conclusion
um but two returning to the issue for a
moment of efficacy and consequences
for um the drugs that are being white
bagged and or or brown bagged
um I heard one of you describe that if
there is a for example a change in the
color uh of the of the medication that
does this might suggest that that it's
efficacy
um has been compromised in in some way
are there other non-observable
Signs by which you can determine whether
a medication that's been white bagged or
brown bag has lost its Effectiveness or
acquired deleterious consequences for
patients and have there been any
instances in which you have been on the
receiving end of complaints from
patients who have suggested such
I'll answer part one regarding the
schematic and you are absolutely right
that the orange side of the left side of
the model is much more convoluted and
has several steps in which there could
be problems with the medication being
compromised not received having to be
wasted Etc
the green side of the model clearly is
if the medications in the hospital or
The provider's Possession the entire
time then there is very clear way in
which that medication is kept safe for
the patient and I think I'll ask you to
answer the second part so I think your
second question was around are there any
other ways to identify whether or not a
medication one of two and the second was
have you ever received any complaints of
of deleterious or adverse consequences
or non-effectiveness that you could
might attribute to Brown bagging a white
bag thank you
so it's so aside from like looking at
deterioration of of a medication or a
change in color would be really
difficult unless you're going to send
the medication for testing to determine
whether or not there's any sort of loss
of potency which a lot of places we just
obviously not able to do that
um in terms of have there been any
adverse outcomes
I think once again a lot of these are
being done in the clinic are the
infusion spaces and you're looking for
you know whether or not there's been a
readmission whether or not somebody's
ended up in your hospital I think most
of the times it's probably due to the um
the delay in care it's really hard to
say if something would be due to the
potency of the medication
representative spear
thank you
Okay so
if we're if we are to consider
uh eliminating Brown bagging and white
bagging and the idea that the hospital
prepares these preparations
with all of the
places all of the cases that we use
kind of cocktail medications
how are you how on Earth do you mean an
inventory like that I mean we're talking
about a lot of variations and a lot and
yours as a result of them sitting in
your hospitals do they kind of
deteriorate we have a very significant
excuse me a very
um
good just-in-time inventory process
where for our infusion spaces and our
Clinic spaces we can see which patients
are coming in and we can order the
medications just in time to ensure that
they're on hand for the patients when
they come in
foreign
thank you Mr chair so in when you say
that the meds can only be seen you can't
really tell and you administer these to
folks do you keep any records when
people
either get sick from it or haven't had
the benefit of the drug and I mean where
are the statistics on on between the two
do you have any
so each hospital has
um
have
reporting mechanisms that would occur
these are voluntary reporting mechanisms
so we would have to either have the
patient come in
our emergency department or report it
back to their primary care physician
that's
they didn't you know something happened
either they had an adverse effect
they didn't see the outcome that they
would have thought they would have seen
and then we would have to ensure that
that event was actually recorded
um
I would say having previously been a
medication safety officer at a at a
community hospital
um
reporting although we try to increase
the reporting we don't get every single
report of an adverse event or even a
medication error
follow-up question
so there's really no way to know what
kind of difference there is between the
bagging and the non-bagging regardless
of the color whether you're in the
hospital or you're getting that at home
and bringing it to your provider because
there's really no
reliable statistics
for us to look at and weigh I mean once
again you're looking you're it's
voluntary reporting so I'm not going to
say that we've never had an adverse
outcome at any of our hospitals in the
state of New Hampshire I'm sure we have
but I would say that it may it we know
that quality control we're not sure how
patients are storing their medications
and we can't guarantee the potency of it
we're you know the provider or the nurse
in the clinics will look at the
medication to to make sure that it looks
appropriate but you don't know and so
it's really
um
I think the biggest things are the
timeliness of care
along with
the you know ensuring that quality
control as well one more follow-up on
that oh sorry okay so so when the
patient is in there and they have they
have their labs and it doesn't work out
do they stay there the whole time and
how long do they wait to get that care
as they're making these drugs and do you
generally have the drugs on hand so what
would happen is that that medication
would likely have to be wasted
right so that's
the met we would have to then buy and
Bill right we would then have to use the
hospital's medication to treat the
patient because the medication that we
received they no longer fit the criteria
for so
um we would throw it away
it's that patient's medication we can't
do anything with it and have to come
back next week
I will just add um even though we don't
necessarily have statistics
um two years ago we had done an
extensive study with our hospitals and
gathered patient stories and patient
experiences specifically our Brown about
Brown bagging and white bagging which we
could share with the committee great
we'll look forward to seeing that in the
subcommittee thank you thank you very
much Gerald Colin Heidi Kroll uh
representing
ahip who opposes Bill uh support with
him it will support the bill if there
was an amendment I think
foreign
good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee excuse me I'm
recovering from having lost my voice
yesterday so hopefully it sticks with me
um for the record my name is Heidi Kroll
Heidi Kroll I work at Gallagher Callahan
and gartrell I'm here today representing
ahip which is America's health insurance
plans
um we appreciate the opportunity to
testify
for reasons that I will explain
um ahip feels that the bill is not
necessary but
with the amendment that the prime
sponsor has introduced today we do think
in Clarity of the bill and that would I
think be acceptable to us the amendment
that he has brought in there is still
Section 1 Roman 3 in the bill around
Brown bagging and um I meant I spoke
with a sponsor earlier I think we can
work together a little bit to clarify my
understanding is that he would like it
to be an opt out I mean sorry an opt-in
provision
that would be a patient decision I think
we could just tighten up that language
there
um
so I'll start by saying that ahip
strongly believes that everyone should
be able to afford uh their prescriptions
um to get access to their prescriptions
and at a price that they can afford our
remarks today are offered to help New
Hampshire achieve that goal
the setting of drug prices starts first
and foremost with the drug manufacturers
however other players in the supply
chain contribute to higher drug prices
as well the focus of today's bill is on
the
um frankly outrageous hospital and
physician markups on prescription drugs
most notably specialty drugs that are
administered by providers in a clinical
setting
specialty drugs are the very expensive
medications that treat complex chronic
or rare conditions such as cancer
multiple sclerosis and rheumatoid
rheumatoid arthritis physician or
Hospital administered specialty drugs
are those that cannot be administered by
the patient they are typically infused
or injected by health care provider in a
physician's office a clinic an infusion
center or hospital setting
specialty drug prices are high and
they're growing quickly specialty drugs
account for approximately two percent
two percent of prescriptions but more
than 50 percent of expenditures
the price of specialty drugs can range
from thousands to tens of thousands of
dollars or more per regimen so they're
quite expensive prescription drugs are
the most significant and fastest growing
portion of your health care premium
dollar
typically A clinician-administered drugs
have been purchased by the provider or
the hospital directly from wholesalers
the drug cost is then marked up
substantially by the provider or the
hospital which bills the insurance or
the payer like a self-funded employer
for the marked up prescription drug and
this is referred to as the buy and Bill
model
is important to note that provider that
the provider or hospital bills
separately for administering the drug to
the patient so that's including the
provider's time and any facility fees so
really the the payer the carrier or the
self-funded payer gets one bill for the
marked up drug price and a separate bill
for the provider to administer the drug
to the patient
the markups on clinician administered
drugs are massive process profit centers
for providers and hospitals several
recent Studies have demonstrated that
this buy-in Bill Revenue maker has
resulted in average markups of 200 to
400 percent Nationwide this is on top of
the already very high drug prices set by
the manufacturers
so these physician markups are well
documented and they are significant as I
mentioned for example a 2018 study by
the Moran company found that on average
hospitals charge 479 percent of their
costs for drugs Nationwide the study
goes on to report that most hospitals 83
percent charge patients and insurers
more than double their acquisition cost
of the medicine marking up the medicines
200 or more
the majority of hospitals 53 percent
markup medicines between 200 to 400
percent on average a small share of
hospitals one in six charge seven times
the price of the medicine and one out of
12 hospitals
has an average charge markup greater
than a thousand percent
so there are other very reputable
studies that reach similar findings
and more alarming is the finding that
hospitals to participate in the federal
340b program charging on average nearly
400 percent of their costs for patients
Cancer drugs
in January of 2021 article written by Dr
Adam fine a nationally recognized expert
on pharmaceutical economics and the drug
distribution system
he looked at payer prices for selected
physician administered drugs and he
writes that contrary to popular belief
hospitals not drug makers keep about 80
percent of when insurers pay for these
provider administered drugs and after
the 340b discounts hospitals keep an
even greater share so my point in all of
this is that physician administered
specialty drugs are a big business for
larger Hospital systems National
Hospital Pharmacy surveys show that
between 2015 and 2019 ownership of a
specialty pharmacy by large hospitals
increased from 44 percent to 89 percent
and again Dr Adam fine described the
data showing that nine out of every 10
large hospitals own a specialty pharmacy
by 2019.
New Hampshire is not immune one of New
Hampshire's Pharmacy hospitals Pharmacy
businesses recently increased Revenue
not related to patient medical care for
the first quarter of fiscal year 2023 by
31.5 million compared to the same
three-month period for the prior year so
annualize this quarterly increase of
31.5 million is more than 120 million
year-over-year increase in revenues from
the hospital's Pharmacy businesses
um and this increase tracks this
particular Hospital's last five years of
impressive Revenue growth due to its
expansion
of its contract and Specialty Pharmacy
the escalating costs of
clinician-administered drugs and the
growing need for an affordable
alternative sparked Market disruption of
the traditional buy and Bill model in
other words competition entered the
picture and ahip fully supports
market-based Solutions
so third-party specialty pharmacies that
are nationally accredited by the same
organizations as the hospital-owned
specialty pharmacies have entered the
marketplace specifically to deliver
medications safely and affordably to
hospitals and other health care
facilities and to help patients and
employers actually afford the
life-saving medications
health insurance companies self-funded
plans and government payers are fighting
for more affordable drugs by Contracting
with third-party specialty pharmacies
that meet the same high standards as the
hospital pharmacies and supplying
patients with the physician administered
drugs through white bagging and brown
bagging
as you've heard weight bagging is um
white bagging and brow bagging where the
third party specialty pharmacies ship
medicines either directly to the patient
that's brown bagging or to the health
care provider that's white bagging
developed those practices developed
precisely because the hospital-based
delivery of these medications has become
too expensive
um
hospitals claim that brown bagging and
white bagging are unsafe for patients
those claims are simply untrue
um and frankly they're a red herring
Brown bagging and white bagging are safe
the real issue is the brown baggy and
white bagging offer a cost-effective
competitive alternative to the
hospital's highly lucrative buy and Bill
model and the hospitals frankly don't
like that
third-party specialty pharmacies or
lower lowering Patients health care
costs by providing a safe lower cost
alternative
the result is Meaningful savings for
employers public payers health insurance
companies patients and taxpayers
thousands of patients successfully and
safely receive their drugs through Brown
bagging and white bagging each and every
year
in eurax which is a national
accreditation
organization in urac's 2021 Specialty
Pharmacy aggregate summary performance
report they report that 40.5 million
specialty prescription drugs were
dispensed in the U.S in 2021.
99.98 percent of prescriptions were
dispensed with no errors and
99.95 percent of prescriptions were
distributed with no errors
it's important to note that third-party
specialty pharmacies are only used for
certain prescription drugs that can
actually be safely delivered through
brown or white bagging and only when the
patient is an appropriate candidate for
such forms of dispensing
all specialty pharmacies must abide by
all state and federal legal and
regulatory requirements in addition to
meeting extra safety requirements for
specialty drugs imposed by the FDA and
by the drug manufacturers themselves
in addition to the extremely stringent
safety requirements health plans always
have exception processes in place to
address the rare circumstances of
quality safety medical necessity and or
care Interruption so for example you've
heard today that people's care may be
delayed that is not true there are
exception processes that the carriers
have to allow a patient to be taken care
of to have their drugs administered when
they're there in the in the clinical
setting
Health Plans develop their Specialty
Pharmacy programs with all potential
dosing and treatment dispensing
scenarios in mind in fact medications
are routinely shipped with enough
additional Supply so that facilities can
adjust a dose as required at the time of
administration
the processes for delivering medications
through specialty pharmacies are the
same as those used when hospitals
acquire the drugs themselves in fact
many hospitals and physician groups
obtain their medications from the same
specialty pharmacies and they use the
same delivery companies and procedures
to serve their patients
for example if you were to go to the
webpage for Dartmouth Hitchcock's
Specialty Pharmacy prescription Services
you will see that it states your
refrigerated medications will be shipped
overnight at no charge via FedEx
all non-refrigerated medications are
shipped via USPS or FedEx should there
be a delay you will be notified to
prevent interruptions and therapy please
call the Dartmouth Hitchcock Pharmacy
within one business day to report
missing or damaged contents so you know
they're dealing basically with the exact
same systems that specialty pharmacies
are dealing with
one final point to keep in mind is that
the state of New Hampshire appears to be
using brown bagging and white bagging
presumably to save its employees and
taxpayers money if you go to the
Department of administrative services
website and pull up their active
employee prescription drug benefit
program you will see under their
specialty medications that all specialty
medications are provided by a third
party Specialty Pharmacy
um
so in some we do not support placing any
bans or restrictions around Brown
bagging or white bagging the effect if
you were to do that would one to would
be to eliminate a critical market-based
tool to lowering the cost of physician
administered drugs and the second
frankly would be if you were to place a
complete ban on everything would be to
Grant essentially a statutory Monopoly
on the supply of physician administered
drugs to the hospital-owned pharmacies
and you know the result would be nothing
short of
uh unfettered um price hikes for granite
Staters so again we do uh having just
seen the amendment today but
um it appears to us that we could
support the amendment that the prime
sponsor has brought in and we will work
with him um on the uh clarifying the
opt-in on the brown bagging
thank you so before I take questions
going back to that phrase in the
amendment that I'm looking at the
pair preferred Pharmacy provider so you
don't have this now in your contracts
with these pharmacies with the hospitals
so so not all carriers are using brown
bagging and white bagging some are just
doing the best well I'm talking about
reimbursement right when there's winds
being concocted inside the pharmacy so I
think the the way that language would
work under as I understand the amendment
that
um any Hospital could pull off their
shelf what they would like to use to
administer to the patient and uh the way
the language reads the reimbursement
rate is kind of the any willing provider
that we have in the pharmacy anyway so
that that price that the why haven't you
fixed that in your contracts
why haven't you why isn't why doesn't
the insurance company have in their
contracts this map or whatever we had
with any willing provider Pharmacy bill
that whatever that minimum manufacturer
that price why why aren't you holding
the hospitals and saying too bad you
want for
you know you're you can't get that much
you know this is what we have in our
formulary and I think it's a great
question I think the folks at the
carriers who do the Contracting should
that's that's my head scratcher here I
mean why why is this problem here at all
I mean doing that you know all we hear
is insurance companies you know we'll
pay what they feel like it yeah that's
why how can you be held you know hostage
by a hospital Unless somehow you they
because you have to have them in your
network then they get to say no you
can't have that clause in this contract
well I think I think that's what I'm
afraid of yeah I think that um the
option having the option the tool in the
toolbox if you will
um to have white bagging and brow
bagging available does lend some
negotiating
um leverage I guess you know versus
having you that we'd say that that they
have to put this in the contract that
they have to take the same price that
anybody else would have to take whether
your preferred Pharmacy is manufacturing
right so this competitive alternative
allows I think that in the negotiation
process okay now representative Herbert
my answer
um so my question was you mentioned an
amendment or an area of agreement you
may be able to come to with the sponsor
and you didn't explain the details at
that time but it sounds to me like you
just did I so uh I am known to cut to
the Chase
and not everywhere
so so
anyway I think
I'm glad that you found the answer John
okay great
representative gifts thank you Mr
chairman I did not hear you say what
ahip stands for oh you tell us what it
stands for please I apologize yes ahip
stands for America's health insurance
plans we are the trade Association for
the health insurance companies
um National Organization
um
yes she represents all of them yeah it
works every day to try to keep our
premiums uh health insurance affordable
okay everybody else oh yeah
representative purcelli a clarification
one more time so I understand the safety
concerns which are separate but I'm
talking I'm uh concerned about the
affordability or the billing so I think
what we're suggesting is that instead of
saying we're segregating these specialty
drugs so the hospitals
can figure out what their pricing is
that they must use the standard pricing
that's out in the marketplace is that
those well we learned it in other builds
there's there's their their minimum
pricing you know right and uh so why
wouldn't it apply to this why doesn't it
play here yeah right okay
and to be clear
um we didn't see the necessity for the
bill
um so but you know we're we're happy if
there is no bill
um but if there is a bill we support the
amendment and then right but we like to
lower health insurance costs so we do
too
okay a quick follow-up would be
um so is there an amendment to say that
we're not going to outright ban the
brown or white bagging but it could be a
option well we have to kind of sort
through the sub in the subcommittee what
this language in front of us does
yes it is
right my understanding is that this the
prime sponsor of the bill has submitted
an amendment to the committee
um and I spoke with him prior
um that there might be some additional
clarification around opting into the
brown bagging exactly but again our
position first and foremost is that we
don't think the bill is thank you very
much
um I I the insurance department put in a
card here and I'm dying to hear what you
have to say but I I know that uh Sabrina
you know also had a card in sooner but
I'm sure she'll feel like her testimony
has been well spoken already but I'll
let you I'll just
let them go ahead here
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to uh to
testify today I hoped that I wouldn't
have to I'll be completely candid when
representative Magoo offered me this
bill I said we don't need it and then
when he showed me the amendment today I
said it was a masterful way to weave in
uh some some kind of uh positive uh
Improvement in the white bagging Brown
bagging discussion
um so what happened I think it's hard to
compete with uh with what uh Heidi Kroll
just said in large part Alex and I can
talk to how this works ultimately what
we want is providers and carriers to
negotiate how they're going to handle
the billing of these Services of these
specialty pharmacies how they're going
to deliver them who's going to cure them
who's going to keep them in the fridge
um what what allows that to happen what
allows those parties to come to the
table with equal bargaining power or
somewhat equal bargaining power is the
possibility that white bag no Brown
bagging is an alternative our fear is
that if if it in a situation where white
bag and brown bag was taken off the
table you would upset the scales of
bargaining power
um for the part of this bill that
addresses things that they have not
contracted to and so this is some I
presume some very specialty formula
medication that was disrupted in transit
that there is a uh agreed upon fair
market value map for that is wonderful
and that wasn't something we had
considered before ultimately the party
should negotiate that and they are
sophisticated and can do that and so
though we don't take positions on stuff
amendment 432h is masterful for what
it's trying to do
is that ditto Alex
you know and um I wanted to mention that
uh when we did the fiscal know uh for
this bill we expressed concerns that it
might escalate uh health insurance costs
and uh we feel very differently about
the amendment
perfect
great thank you guys okay one card left
oh represent representative we almost
made it
I'm looking at the fiscal notes so the
fiscal notes with the amendment no
longer apply is that what you're saying
that is correct and then
State action to add a health benefit
which is above or in addition to the
essential health benefits all that does
that all that comes up it all goes away
all right thank you
thank you thank you all right Sabrina
Dunlap
you're you're all set you're good I
figured so
okay with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 513
and I'll take up our very last bill
I'm sorry okay
uh house build 304 relative to Advanced
Driver assisted systems disclosures by
auto glass repair or replacement
facilities
and
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee talk about one having
nothing to do with the other
here's my send my pink card up on that
other than they had the same sponsor
yes
that's why they're scheduled this way
exactly and I really appreciate that
courtesy I really do
and because Taylor wanted me to move it
off too so he has himself to blame
yes I was traveling out of the out of
the country
so I do I really do appreciate that
um so this one's a hopefully quite a bit
simpler it is really good to see you
again yeah famous last words really good
to see you again uh twice in one day
really a privilege um there were copies
of an amendment that went around on this
one too
um it was not an all after the enacting
Clause uh it's zero five zero nine h
on this one and it replaced section one
of the bill I have some copies here is
anybody how many copies do you have well
I delivered 20 before lunch so you
should all have I have one here yeah so
there's some extras I'll leave them up
here at the table for anybody else who's
testifying in case you didn't get them
anyways hopefully it's pretty quick um
I'll hand off some to some experts
behind me after a really quick personal
story
um
so House Bill 304 is a good consumer
protection Bill designed to inform
consumers about some potentially bad
practices that you really could not
possibly know about or at least would be
very unlikely to know about
um
related to windshield repairs uh maybe
one of the simpler car repairs
that everybody runs into especially this
time of year you're driving down the
road you get a windshield chip I had one
uh maybe just barely over a year ago and
I had no idea until I went in to it was
about inspection time I went in for an
oil change in my good faithful dealer
that I've used for years State Motors in
Manchester the one by the Puritan back
room
uh my dealer my service manager John
said do you know you have a big chip and
I said no I don't see any chips and he
goes well it's hidden by the a-pillar
you know the glass extends over
and he said well you can't get it
inspected and it's not not urgent but
it's going to spread to a big crack and
you have a very expensive windshield
because of your heads up display and all
the sensors and blah blah blah you're
gonna have to get it recalibrated
and I said well I'm not too worried
about it because
I have a comprehensive insurance and I
don't think I have a deductible on it so
I'll call Geico so I called Geico and
they said no problem uh zero deductible
schedule an appointment but you have to
go to the dealer I said well it's a good
thing I've already gone to the dealer
and State Motors should handle it
and I called them back and they said you
know checks in the mail uh they said
great let us know when it gets there
it's going to be very expensive and so I
said whatever I ignored them and they
said but it has to be done by a
specialized place
um anyway so I called state orders back
I said send me a loaner car blah blah
blah you get the idea this is should not
be a big deal I essentially ignored
everything the rep uh at the other end
of the Geico
phone call said when they read me this
very long script I completely ignored it
because it's a windshield repair and
everybody has these done in New England
if you drive behind a you know DPW truck
and you have chip anyways
um they said you know something about
recalibration I kind of vaguely remember
it so I brought the my car in
as a truck it's an SUV
um I brought the car in and they I came
back and I couldn't see the navigation
anymore I couldn't read the top of the
map and you know I have one of those
things that projects the speed and the
map and I couldn't read it anymore and
you know I'm not that tall I'm six feet
tall and I had the guy get in he said oh
I can't read it either and they said
okay we'll give you another low car try
again
um
this went on for like several weeks next
thing I know they're taking the dash off
and they're replacing the heads up
display and it's three thousand dollars
and it's four thousand dollars and
thankfully all of this is covered but
they should have to sign the bill every
time
anyways the long and the short of it is
it's a very specialized process
um and they thankfully were using either
safe flight or Portland or one of the
big name places and bringing in a
specialized person to do this but had I
listened carefully or not listened
carefully or I didn't have the right
dealer I may never have known this and I
could have been in a very expensive
process
so when one of the uh folks behind me
that I met 20 some years ago on this
committee called me shortly after I got
elected and said I have a consumer
protection bill and I need someone to
sponsor it I said if I got a story for
you I just went through this and it very
easily could have cost me out of pocket
an awful lot of money taking the dash
off replacing the HUD et cetera et
cetera Etc
so I was reluctant to put in a piece of
legislation that might affect the small
business guy because I don't believe in
unnecessary bills and unnecessary
legislation
so I went to the guy whose son I coached
in football who's owned the local towing
shop and then I went to the guy that
changes my oil on a regular basis and I
went to two or three other repair shops
and I said what about your Auto Glass
business is this going to put you out of
business this is probably a lucrative
thing
and I checked around and they all said
we don't do it we call safe flight
Portland and we all sub it out and we're
not worried about it and we tell our
customers our regular customers
you know leave your car here we'll bring
in the experts we get a you know we get
a little referral fee and we you know we
have our guys and and that's what they
do and you should we have no problem
with you putting in this kind of bill
because all it does is require us to
notify and protect the consumer
and I'm going to leave the rest of the
technicalities I understand there was a
bill in before that was elaborate
there's other states that have done
other things a number of other states
that have enacted complicated pieces of
legislation and this is simple and this
is direct and it requires some simple
consumer protection notification
language
and I'm happy we've gone through some
iterations of the uh the language and
how it is a notification piece and
um I think it's good language they think
it's good language there's some
interested parties that'll tell you some
facts and figures on you know how many
millions of windshields are replaced and
why it's complicated but that's my
personal story and how it came I came to
be prime sponsor on this and it's what
really happened to me and it literally
could have been six grand I mean I
signed the invoices for it so
that's the story about the eight ass
bill so what's the problem we're trying
to fix here the problem is
um an unsuspecting consumer could very
easily go to a fly-by-night auto glass
shop not be told leave and have
non-working Collision sensors radar
sensors laser sensors all the sensors
that are in your complicated windshield
get a get a aftermarket or an average
windshield glass replacement and all of
those important sensors Collision
sensors braking sensors all those things
be completely uncalibrated and never
know it this bill simply says you need
to go get those recalibrated once you
leave here we can do your glass but you
we can't calibrate your system
recalibrate your system right so this
requires notification of that of that so
the consumer
who doesn't know anything about all this
calibration stuff comes in and and
somebody is going to sell them a glass
knowing full well that they can't do the
calibration but they actually can't do
the proper Services correct so once that
person gets in the car and starts
driving away they're going to see that
eventually let's say maybe they don't
see it right away because they're busy
thinking something else but at some
point in time they're going to realize
right away that it doesn't work
what is wrong with our Consumer
Protection Law now
for them to go back to that dealer and
have him say
oh gee I'm so sorry I I screwed up
here's your money back they should be
told before Mr chairman they should be I
mean that's a valid question they should
they should be told up front we can't do
that we can't do that work and here's
where you can go get that work done
and they should be they should be told
up front
that we can't do we can't do that work
and you've got all of these safety
sensors in your car that need to be
addressed I mean Geico was good enough
to me
not everybody has Geico or Progressive
okay
some of the other guys that are in this
business for a living
so under the consumer protection the
penalties
if they want us if the guy assuming says
too bad
or or if the guy says here's your money
back I mean you're just saying sure
Caveat Emptor we cannot we cannot I mean
in terms of even the consumer protection
act can't say to uh somebody that as
long as they give them person the money
back and say whatever their charge is
you know going back and and and and and
that means refunding
but that under the consumer protection
that's all that's the extent of what the
ACT will do now that's all the
requirements yeah so what you're saying
is they have to tell them up front yeah
but if they don't what happens
single production kicks in they'd have
to they have to the only recourse they
would have would be the current consumer
protection act so I guess they think
that's bad I I'm just trying to figure
out what the purpose of the law the
purpose of the purpose of the law is to
notify him up front that they need to
have their system recalibrated
no okay okay okay I mean you could
definitely take the position as this
committee has some number of times that
it's buyer beware and you can't
legislate common sense but I'm saying
that most windshield and I think I think
you're going to hear from some witnesses
behind me that after
2023 certain point in 2023 that all
windshields are going to need
some kind of recalibration and I don't
remember the exact date and the
specifics on that for collisions I'm all
set okay yes okay
The Usual Suspects
I'm going to defer some real technical
questions
we're going to go reverse order
representative Terry first so thank you
so does your bill have in view actual
instances of unscrupulous shall we say
uh repair shop deals who do this work
knowing that they can't do what they
have to do so that I'm sorry to get into
this situation where afterwards as
representative hunt described
um somebody has to resort to a and after
the fact or after the the uh uh the the
damages have been done so to speak uh
process you're trying to preempt all of
this with your bill saying that you have
to notify people in advance and I'm
saying is this really necessary because
you have actual instances where this has
happened to people do I can I provide
you with actual instances where it's
happening or data you just no we're
sanitary I I don't have and I'm sure the
folks behind me do because they're in in
the business in the industry so I I
honestly don't have
um statistics on how often uh
currently fly by night
um repair shops victimize consumers for
Auto Glass so I don't have that data so
This falls into the category of you
think this is a good idea
just occurs to you as a good idea as a
common sense good idea you don't have
instances where we have problems that
you are seeking to do so no I wouldn't I
wouldn't say that it falls onto Falls
onto you know representative's good idea
and I'm trying to solve a problem we
don't have
um it it's like it falls into the
category of Common Sense consumer
protection that a number of other states
have addressed and that we're going to
need to address because all windshields
have this it's a common common sense
consumer protection idea and I will tell
you that there are uh vastly more
qualified experts in this industry that
can speak to the uh the legislation that
some other state and they have the
statistics on it that I just simply
don't have
so they'll speak to it
okay representing Gibbs
thank you Mr chairman is there in your
understanding a safety issue that makes
it important that the consumer received
this information up front about the need
for recalibration
thank you representative Gibbs for your
question I think there's about 30 safety
issues in the various sensors speed
braking uh Collision sensors that make
it that issue that I would like all
those drivers to be aware of so that
they're properly recalibrated uh
follow-up inquiry for the question you
may inquire thank you uh so this isn't
just something that seems to you to be a
common sense good idea but rather
something that is necessary for safety
yes representative Gibbs I I'd like the
driver behind me who's uh texting and I
I
um or you know drinking their coffee for
their windshield sensors to be working
properly
um
for sure yeah
representative spear
the manual for my car very specifically
and I've read my manual front to cover
and back to cover
and it says whatever the words are and
it says very specifically if you remove
the windshield make sure you get it
calibrated It also says if you remove
the battery you got to get something
calibrated It also says if you change
the tires you got to get the sensors
recalibrated I have a list from that
manual what car goes out without a
manual without something in the manual
it tells you to do this
I would uh guess that you're probably in
the minority uh of folks that read the
manual about their windshield
calibration I know that I didn't read it
until after when I was trying to
diagnose this ridiculous HUD problem but
I did find it you're correct mine also
said get the windshield calibrated um
but I didn't know that until it was far
too late
get represented pictures
all right
I had pee on my head a quick question
with the disclosure I'm sorry I couldn't
find it in the bed so um you want
disclosure so what what is it that
you're looking for when you sign the
little piece of paper there's a
paragraph that no one reads that says by
the way you have to recalibrate I'm just
trying to get to the
purpose or the remedy of the bill
you know you they did tell you but you
didn't listen
okay so what is it that you're trying to
do with this bill for disclosure
um thanks for your question uh simply
put I'd like like the Bill calls for a
notification of the consumer that the uh
yeah but how is that how writing he's
asking she's asking you they did notify
you just didn't pay attention
well I mean I suppose that's possible
with any similar notification that the
consumer doesn't pay attention
I want to know specifically what it is
what is the notification process so you
have I don't know it verbally doesn't
work it doesn't know either because he
didn't listen he didn't listen to it so
he has no idea what he installed right
so that's not going to solve the problem
if you have you know the when I get my
oil changed I have to sign the little
contract that I don't read the small
print so that probably won't work how
are we going to make sure that cons and
reading the manual probably won't work
so how are we going to educate uh
consumers to say oh by the way a simple
nothing is simple anymore so when you
want to get the little ding replaced in
your Auto Glass it becomes a pro it
becomes you know an event
vent well so so the bill calls for a
notification in writing or
electronically so that leaves it up to
the repair shop to either provide them
some sort of a written disclosure or
electronic disclosure
I mean that does leave it open uh but it
does have to be in writing I mean they
can email it to them or provide them a
standard form I mean I don't I don't
think we need to be much more specific
than that but but it does make it so
it's not verbal so and it has to be that
the recalibration was not successful or
was not performed
and that the vehicle needs to be taken
to a manufacturer certified dealership
you can read the you see in the text of
the bill
s okay you guys you've already had your
questions
so as luck would have it
uh
this goes to the what's the problem
we I've had I have fancy modern cars
with these fancy modern windshields
and I've I have a son that seems to use
them to catch rocks
uh so I've had four windshields replaced
on two cars in the last nine months
so and I don't know what sort of
requiring tattoos on the people at safe
flight you could possibly ask for
because the insurance company tells me
that you need to have it recalibrated I
suppose there's something in the manual
but I've never looked at it
when you take it into the safe white
place they say well you know it has to
be warm enough so that we can
recalibrate it you go oh okay fine and
then you go back and pick it up the next
day and they said all right we
recalibrated it and do you have any
questions no I've got no questions so
maybe it's safe flight is super duper
good about this and other people aren't
but if you're not a major glass shop you
can't even do one of these windshields
I mean you know
would you believe would you believe I
mean I have I have a 1930 Packard and on
that it says you the spark you
pull out the throttle the choke halfway
give it a yank and it starts I mean
that's the owner's manual a much simpler
project but you can replace the glass on
that you can't replace that on the
on the Cadillac
representative facts and I would believe
that yeah and and thank you for your
question and that's exactly precisely
why you need this bill because not
everyone is safe flight although safe
flight and safe flight is here
and safely is going to tell you
with much more degree of expertise than
I can
um and I and I hope so I I'd like to
conclude my testimony and respect the
committee's afternoon times allow the
experts to elaborate the member is
allowed to no longer take I mean I'll be
happy to take no don't take anymore
[Laughter]
this is a would you believe so you all
you have to do is say yes or no all
right would you believe that you have
provided me with yet another opportunity
to justify to my wife why I am going to
keep my 2000 Camry and not buy a new
vehicle okay yes or no would you believe
yes I would and that's an excellent
thank you thank you and and would you
believe I
went through this 30 years ago
when they used to put the antenna yes in
the glass yes
and
and had to be told by the guy who was
selling my glass to go out and look at
that windshield and do you have that and
I didn't even know I didn't even think
twice about you know that's true I never
really did see the antenna okay so this
is a very old story yep so thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman always a
pleasure all right
yeah you guys ready
okay the chair will call on Scott
uh Zike is that zikies would you want to
like to be called zajac say check isn't
that say jack isn't that Sajak
it's like
oh okay
all right it's God's sake from Safelite
Mr chairman honorable members of this
committee uh my name is Scott Zike and I
work for Safe Light group based out of
Columbus Ohio there's 20 people on this
island safe flight is the leading
provider of vehicle glass repair
replacement and Adas recalibration
services in the country we operate in
all 50 States including here in New
Hampshire
I'll cut really to the chase to try to
answer some of your questions we would
appreciate that yeah
this is this is about safety and because
your forward-facing camera
dictates automatic braking Lane
deviation if that camera's off by a
millimeter that could cause the vehicle
to go 50 feet left 30 feet long on
braking so it's critical
that if you take your car and under New
Hampshire law consumers have a right to
take their car anywhere they want to
take it to get it repaired this bill
doesn't change that but if you go to a
glass shop
and that glass shop should be informing
you that you have an Adas feature that
needs to be recalibrated if they can do
it if they can't they need to push you
in the direction of a quality not just
safe light there's a lot of glass
companies that can do it
you know our business model has changed
because everyone's accustomed to a
one-hour job and we come to you
we have to change that because we cannot
recalibrate outside of a flat surface
protected area
so again if it's not done appropriately
you're still responsible as a consumer
to drive your car
you know you can't solely rely on the
safety features but they're designed to
create the safety zone around your car
and if that camera is not recalibrated
you're in danger
so you should at least be told whether
you have it up front you should be told
if the glass shop can do it doesn't
matter if they can or can't but they
should inform you if they have done it
or if they can't do it if they did it
was it successful
if someone brought up fraud
I can get you the data because there are
glass shops that are out there charging
for recalibrations and they're not doing
it
so they need a recourse first is just to
be informed second is give them an give
them a way to have it
to get a recourse from the Attorney
General's office under the consumer
protection act and that's our goal
this bill is very similar to one that
was passed in Maryland Arizona we're
going to see it hopefully here we're
going to see it in Florida Texas
Illinois Nevada and probably Hawaii this
year and it really is about consumer
protection that's all it's about it's
not about driving people to one shop or
another we just think it's important as
a leading advocate for Consumer
Protection
that you be informed up front to a lot
of people
I've never read my manual
and you should be if you call a glass
shop they should just tell you
by the make and model of your car that
you have the safety feature that needs
to be recalibrated whether they can do
it it's still your choice to take
wherever you want it to go but they need
to inform you whether it was done
successfully and not Bill anybody you as
a consumer or insurance company for
services that are not rendered so that's
the real purpose it is really safety and
consumer protection
and customer satisfaction because the
model has changed when you you're we
used to we'll come to you in your 2000
Camry
but if you have a
2022 Camry you have to come to us
and it and it's a very complicated
process there's a handout if any of you
would like to see a calibration done
come to a shop near you we'll show you
how it's done
um it's it's fascinating because if you
read the handout
every vehicle manufacturer has different
um
mandates or expectations specifications
some is once called a static where you
plug into the car's brain
and you read it to say it's done right
and it says it's done right others say
just get in the car and drive at 50
miles an hour for five minutes some
require both
and the reason why it's important that
we pass this bill is there are incidents
of fraud there's incidents of crashes
and safety and I would just ask for your
support
we support it if we have to make further
amendments we're open to that I can get
the data safety data fraud data for you
all if you take this the subcommittee or
wherever it goes but I would ask you for
your support and I'm open to take any
questions you might have
representative Burroughs
thank you just a quick question when you
buy the car
wouldn't the dealer tell you about the
fee you know when they're selling you
the car they tell you what the features
are and so if it's a it's a I don't know
what to call it a smart window
you would know that you can't just get
the glass fixed I mean when they do that
when the course of selling you the car
well
not necessarily because you have I don't
know I don't know what the dealers do
they might want to talk to that you know
we we're after the fact they're not here
and uh
um but anyway you should be told yeah
and we we do when we when we service you
if someone mentioned it we read the VIN
number and we know on that VIN number
what exact piece of glass needs to go in
and how to
recalibrate the system
now
there again there are some someone
mentioned the term unscrupulous and
there are some bad actors out there this
really doesn't prohibit them from doing
the glass work but it does require them
to inform you as a consumer whether you
need to have it recalibrated or they did
it and did successfully
we try to keep it as simple as possible
representing us
thank you Mr chairman uh would you
believe that
some people
uh when they buy a new car don't buy it
through a dealer that they can talk to
uh specifically would you believe that a
friend told me yesterday that she bought
her new car online and then it was
shipped up to her from South Carolina
and there was no dealer for her to talk
to or to give her any warnings
we had that legislation several years
ago dealing with that problem so and by
the way I'm just trying not to use the
term brown bag and white bags because
you learn more than you ever wanted to
know about bagging and yes that
complicated
now are you from Ohio then what's that
are you from Ohio are you where are you
from I live in Phoenix Phoenix so so you
can go back to Arizona says well I
learned everything about it well in
Columbus there's a brown bag Dolly and I
couldn't get over there right now you
can tell them well I apologize for
scheduling the bills like I did no
problem but uh thank you very much for
your testimony I'll see you again thank
you
any other questions uh nope but we have
one more card thank you Mr chairman
Bonnie wheeler
in support of the bill
and I assume Glass America also is
qualified to
do this yes
and Auto Glass Safety Council
Mr chair members of the House the
Commerce and the consumer affairs
committee thank you for the privilege of
submitting this testimony in support of
the HB 304 my name is Bonnie wheeler I'm
an area Marketing Manager for Glass
America it's a National Auto Glass
company with seven employees in the
local Manchester shop
as a marketing manager I cover all of
New Hampshire as well as parts of
Vermont in Massachusetts I've been in
the auto glass business since
1998. the last two years for The Glass
America and previously worked for
Safelite as well as other glass
companies I make my residence here in
Newport New Hampshire
I am proud to work for a company that
takes safety seriously as evidenced by
its membership in the auto glass Safety
Council or agsc an agsc members such as
Glass America follow the auto glass
replacement safety standard
voluntary industry standard approved by
the American national standards
Institute and has been in place for 20
years
agsc members also agree to random
independent third-party audits to only
employ agsc trained and certified glass
technicians it's my understanding that
the agsc has submitted written
testimonies in support of this bill
technology is rapidly changing the
industry and auto glass companies such
as Glass America and its technicians
need to be up on the latest changes and
safety guidelines modern vehicles
equipped with electronic safety features
need to be thoroughly reviewed prior to
windshield replacement and the camera in
the windshield absolutely needs to be
recalibrated once the new windshield is
then installed we agree that HB 304 will
make sure that the customers are fully
informed regarding the recalibration
process and the vehicles are returned to
them in their same safe working order we
might suggest that if the legislature is
to examine Auto Glass safety it should
not limit itself to calibration issues
but look at all the issues covered by
the agsc safety standard
in reviewing the bill one element that
we found to be a little confusing was to
ensure that the requirements of section
4 notifying the customer if a
recalibration was not performed or not
completed successfully is done in the
invoice after work is completed and not
in the description of the work to be
done required in section three perhaps a
few words added to section 4 can clarify
that I thank you for your time and
interest and I'm happy to answer any
questions if I can
foreign
thank you very much
okay having no
more cards we will close the public
hearing on 304. so
um for those who are still here uh yes
we will not be here tomorrow
all right we're all done and then in
terms of next week
um I'm I'm I uh I'm gonna give everybody
an extra day off so we're not going to
bother
um doing anything on Tuesday
um and so it's the assumption is that
we're probably going to have a session
both Wednesday and Thursday given that
all all these bills and then I my past
experience is that it's going to take
two days I mean you know fortunately for
Commerce uh it won't won't be very long
it'll be a quickie but I'm sure other
committees will be much more time
consuming when when will this committee
meeting okay
so we will be back
[Music]
um
the March
7th 8th ninth week that week and I will
I um and when I'll be doing what will be
doing that that first week because we
have we have to have everything out of
committee by uh March 16th
which I believe is a Thursday so that
means we will be subcommitting
um to the different committees we'll be
subcommitting those two uh that first
week
so expect to that on that too you know
that well schedule
um I mean how does everybody feel about
meeting in another room Tuesday so that
we don't have to come in on Thursdays
how do people
Judd
well because normally we're supposed to
as a committee we're supposed to be
Wednesday Thursday
and the problem for me you know it's
only my problem is that we have
Chairman's meetings on Tuesday Mornings
so I hate to just come in just for the
meeting so that's why I would prefer to
do Tuesday Wednesday
and then give and then have Thursday
free so expect that that would be March
7th and 8th and I will schedule I will
schedule everything we have left into a
subcommittee so we'll have an
opportunity to talk about all the bills
we have left
in the subcommittee
we've seen them all
it was put the pedal to the metal and we
got her done
um so having said that then the
following week again we'll have a
wrap-up cleanup of all the subcommittee
works but that uh by the the 15th
The Ides of March
we will exec every bill that's left in
committee
okay now many people think it's a Marvel
that we do the Commerce does that but
that's because we do everything through
subcommittee so by the time we have the
full committee we just
we
that's how that's how I've done it for
the last 20 years believe it or not and
I'm like I think I'm the only committee
that Congress is the only committee who
did it but but I know it was good
because when Ed Butler was in the chair
he did the same thing when
so with that uh you guys all have a
wonderful
vacation the following week